federal prosecutors
are considering whether or not they can
charge many of the people involved in
the ride at the capitol with felony
murder and it's just one of the story
one of the stories that's coming out
showing the reaction to those who
stormed the capital the logic here is
that
if you are with you if you are part of a
group that is in the process of
committing a crime and someone dies
then you get charged with felony murder
in this regard they're saying
not everybody but a large portion of the
people who are there
who are part of that melee who are
breaking in may all
actually face those charges and that
will be
probably hundreds of people we've seen
similar things kind of
in 20 2017 on january 20th when trump
was being inaugurated
several hundred antifa types and you
know wearing all black got arrested and
they tried charging them
all with conspiracy under the idea
that by wearing black they were aiding
and abetting the other people who were
committing crimes it did not fly
so this might not either and they might
not even do it but this is the only
thing that's happening to trump
supporters following what happened at
the capitol
parlor as you know was shut down they're
now fighting back filing a lawsuit
against amazon and this is really
interesting because
the lawsuit makes some really
interesting points at the same time
amazon was claiming parlor wasn't
policing this criminal
activity which was people inciting
violence and calling for death and
things like that
they they they say um parlor wasn't
doing that so we're going to terminate
you without notice breaching the
contract
part according to parlor and they said
at the same time hang mike pence was
trending on twitter
and there was no application or threats
or removal from twitter for the same
thing
and they note recently amazon signed a
multi-year contract with twitter to
handle their data
so this looks more like anti-competitive
action from
a cabal of silicon valley elites
considering parlor was
the fastest growing network the number
one app on
uh the itunes store seems particularly
well it seems like they may be right but
we've got another story too there's
there's video going around of a guy
getting kicked off a plane
apparently many of these people at the
at the capitol were put on a no-fly list
so
things are getting particularly crazy
we've got facebook censorship hitting
we've got cumulus radio telling you know
many conservatives that if you say the
election was stolen
they're going to nuke you out right here
it comes man the purge is going to be
long lasting
there's talks of widespread armed
protests around the country through the
next
several days maybe a couple weeks and
into the 20th so
we got a lot to talk about hanging out
with us today is of course andrew from
don't walk run productions
howdy now you're the senior political
analyst
yes the senior political analyst on uh
on my channel and
the number one senior political analyst
on youtube so
you're sorry you didn't quite make chief
no i'm a humble guy i'm i'm humble you
know i don't need
i don't need uh to be called president
or
ceo or tim paul you know i don't i don't
need to
heaven forbid i use my name on my own
i'm sorry sorry looks hanging out and
they went after ron paul
my goodness i got a lot to say about
that hi
i am the sensei behind we are change.org
and it's been really nice communicating
to everyone on that top right hand
corner when people pull in put in their
emails in this slew of all this
censorship that's going on we are change
the work top right hand corner nice
talking to all of you amazing people
wait i need to stress too yeah the ron
paul thing how dare they
seriously the weirdest thing is the
people like on on reddit
ragging on ron paul and i'm like what
he's like an old man was like freedom
he's calling for peace in the middle
east and he criticized donald trump
more than i think a lot of people on the
left effectively it's because they have
no
i'm sure there's a lot of people who are
like i guess ron paul's bad
uh there's a lot we got to talk about i
know people are just going crazy calling
people misogynist to white supremacists
and a lot of other people and a lot of
other kind of libertarians
anti-establishment
and cap types who are like wait wait
wait hold on this is not about maga
ron paul was against uh the larger
foreign policy of donald trump he
criticized them on so many police state
issues
and and now he's a part of the clan that
you know the group think mentality is
saying he's
it he's a part of the mega crowd got to
take him out sorry we have one more
important part we got
we have two more important people to
enjoy as well so we got ian ian has two
gorillas
i do have two gorillas one and gorilla
too so the gorilla shirt
it's on the it's on the store but it's
not youtube hasn't approved it i guess i
don't know how that works but
there's there's we're making another one
we've we and we might have a limited
edition
one where it's the same shirt but he's
wearing a tinfoil hat okay so that'll be
like a bonus
maybe it may be like an exclusive
purchase or something so well
what's going on ian you know not much i
have actively not been engaged much in
the in the news media today except for
watching that guy at the airport get
get told he was on a no-fly list i mean
once you hear the the pain
in the individual's voice i think is
when it really for me is when it really
hits home what
what what we could end up doing to these
people inadvertently
and all of our all of us inadvertently
incrementally if somebody committed a
crime like that dude who
you know the people who are attacking
the cops and like literally killed the
guy
those people go to jail of course i
think so yeah but there's there's a lot
of people who are being falsely accused
they're just because they're they're
near there and their photos were there
in the new york times we had richie on
the show
and the new york times put up a caption
saying he was a writer who punched the
glass
when he was actually just like my phone
it fell he's a journalist
and and with elijah that's crazy stuff
so we'll talk about all this
don't forget star patch lid is over here
pressing i am over here in the corner
pushing buttons
ladies and gentlemen we once again have
a sponsor i'm eternally grateful because
in these trying times when people are
getting nuked and banned
and we have no idea what's gonna happen
it's more important than ever that we we
have people who are willing to support
the show so i'm eternally grateful
today's sponsor is keto elevate from
biotrust you can check it out at
eatrightandfeelwell.com
this is for those that want a diet or
actually just eat right it's not even
about trying to lose weight or anything
i guess diet just
does just mean eat right it's medium
chain triglyceride powder you mix it in
your smoothies i
we just did like some strawberries and
some yogurt mix it in it's really really
good
and the thing about medium chain
triglycerides i was reading this is
crazy stuff i don't know a whole lot
about all the science
but it actually if you're doing the keto
diet converts to ketones
better than long chain triglycerides so
they say this is better than coconut oil
you get this special blend from eat
right and feelwell.com
so check it out if you order now it's 51
percent off there's a lot of cool things
that come with it if you're interested
in in you know getting supplements
something's going to help you out
they got a 60 day money back guarantee
so if you have any issues you can you
can hit them back up
they say keto elevate provides your body
only c8 the most ketogenic medium chain
triglyceride in its purest form that
means it provides very fast and
effective support
it's going to make you feel like you got
better at more energy healthy appetite
management
better athletic performance now here's
the cool parts free shipping
and if you order today they're going to
donate to a hungry child in your honor
through their partnership with no no kid
hungry.org
to date they have provided over 4.4
million meals to hungry kids
so please help biotrust hit that goal of
5 million meals 5 million meals this
year again
eat right and feelwell.com plus you get
a free vip live health and fitness
coaching from biotrust's
team of expert nutrition and health
coaches
for life with every order wow really for
life
man that's really worth it cool this is
cool we really do have we have a bunch
of this stuff downstairs i'm not even
kidding
and so uh you know i i skated today we
make smoothies with them they also have
the collagen stuff so again
biotrust thank you so much for your
sponsorship of the show considering
politics is getting so
insane anybody willing to help support
our work and the things we talk about
you guys you guys really do rock so once
again
eatrightandfeelwell.com check it out and
again thanks
let's uh let's jump over the first story
the story about
prosecutors this is from wtop news
this is a local dc prosecutor's way
heavy hammer
felony murder for rioters in capital
officers
death they say as federal prosecutors
filed charges against writers who took
part
in last wednesday's violent take over
the us capital investigators continue to
gather
evidence in the death of capitol police
officer brian siknik
who died from injuries sustained during
the attack while most murder
investigations folk
on focus on the person or persons who
caused the fatal injury
former federal prosecutor tim heaphy
said prosecutors could charge many
rioters
with felony murder even if they were
nowhere near sicknick
heaphy led the month-long investigation
to law enforce law enforcement
performance before
during and after the deadly 2017 rally
in charlottesville
heaphy was in the u.s attorney for
western district of virginia from
december 09
through january 2015 appointed by obama
under the doctrine of felony murder
which applies in the district of
columbia any murder that occurs during
the commission
of one of several underlying felonies is
chargeable as felony murder saying quote
the classic example is if three guys go
to rob a convenience store
and one guy is the getaway driver if in
the commission of the robbery the clerk
was shot and killed
all three of the participants in the
robbery of the store are potentially
guilty of felony murder
on january 6 as most of you know there
was a raucous event at the capitol some
call it an insurrection some call it a
riot some called storming
they say in the federal murder code 11
underlying felonies which can be part of
a felony murder charge are listed one
which could be applicable to the january
6 takeover is burglary
quote you could look at the storming of
the doors of the capitol by that riotous
mob as
burglary if they went in with the intent
to steal
disrupt proceedings to commit other
offenses they committed burglary
and therefore a murder that occurred
during the course of a burglary
could be potentially charged as felony
murder the mere act of breaking the
capital doesn't constitute burglary
uh prosecutors would need to prove that
they intended to do something criminal
once they were inside
let's say somebody storms the capital
with the intent to disrupt congress
or steal the sign outside of speaker
pelosi's door and there's a murder that
occurs in the midst of that
he could be charged with felony murder
as with any crime federal or state
prosecutors have to weigh
whether charges can be sustained in
court they say in this case with crimes
committed on federal property
and then in the death of a federal
employee the us attorney for the
district of columbia
which prosecutes cases in both federal
and local courts would have the felony
murder account at its disposal so i'll
say this
it wasn't just the officer who died it
was ashley babbitt
i think they if they go this route and
they could i i'm not entirely sure they
will
they could actually charge these people
maybe even every single person who went
in the building
with the death of ashley babbitt because
a death occurred in the commission of a
crime
there's a lot of things that are crazy
about this there have been photos
popping up of random people who are
like well i mean most people are kind of
random in a sense but some people who
weren't even in the building
people are doxing them and saying they
were there that's enough that's all that
matters some people who weren't in the
building at all
and in the case of the new york times we
just mentioned this richie mcginnis
who's been on the show several times
who's a journalist
he's actually the journalist who tried
to save the life of the man who was shot
in kenosha wisconsin earlier this year
he's he's
up against a window pointing down and
the new york times ran a caption saying
that he was a rioter who punched the
glass
when they wouldn't let him in which is
just not true he dropped his phone and
he was trying to ask someone to pick it
up for him
so this is where things get weird if
they actually i guess the question is
are they going to go after all of the
trump supporters with an iron fist
when you look at black lives matter and
how the district attorneys were
releasing these people and not charging
them
there's a question of whether or not
they're going to be biased against
conservatives
and just run them through the you know
run them over the coals throw the book
at them
or are they going to be worried about
you know potentially setting off some
kind of
political spark by going for trump
supporters in this way
um i think a couple things one
this whole felony murder thing is an
overreach in
in the worst way because when you talk
about
three or four people robbing a
convenience store
it's all coordinated it's all planned
they
they
are in cahoots with each other
all the people that stormed the capital
they didn't know each other were they on
were they all on parlor and saying hey
let we're we're gonna do this particular
thing they didn't even know
these people didn't even know each other
so you can't say that
or or the person that shot david dorn do
you go well
everybody who was committed who was part
of the riot
is complicit you can't say that that's
the question of bias all right well here
he
wouldn't do that for the riots in black
with black lives matter would they do it
here well that's different
it's it's it's a different story too
because you're talking about district
attorneys on a local level on a state
level
now with since this happened on federal
property
you're talking about the doj and the up
the incoming doj
so you're probably not going to see your
it's all this talk about charges
but you're not going to see anything
really come about until
after biden is not exactly yeah unless
unless trump comes out and just sweeping
pardons everybody
i i actually made a joke on my twitter
about that i think it's gonna happen uh
no it won't but uh
well yeah because trump doesn't have any
but it could be but that that would be
that would be
kind of a bold move when you say well
another thing to really kind of
understand here i remember seeing
someone post
and saying well it's good to see that
the fbi could be effective
when they want to be and we have to
admit the fbi has been pulling out all
the stops there's videos of them of
showing up at people's homes stopping
people at airports they're putting up
signs on bus stops
so they're doing everything in their
power and utilizing
all of their power in an extensive way
which
seems like they're activated in a way
that they weren't before and if we're
going to look at responsibility i mean
there's already some investigations
going around the capitol police there's
some officers suspended
but wasn't it wasn't there six requests
that were denied for extra police
assistance by the mayor's office
no no no not by the mayor's office who's
this it was by uh capitol police by the
capitol police
six times they got denied the the mayor
this is really interesting muriel bowser
was according to the new york times
concerned about having an excessive
police presence following a summer of
riots and the criticism of over policing
she was like i don't want it we want
limited you know national guard just
guiding traffic
and some police and so she said a narrow
unarmed mission
that's crazy six times they asked they
said we need more police for this and
they're like nah
well see that's that's the thing um when
you read twitter and everybody goes
didn't you see this coming we saw this
coming we all saw coming you're like
well the mayor didn't the the black
mayor
of washington dc didn't so if she didn't
then well she put out a statement
on the fifth saying like i'll make it
clear i am not requesting a strong
police presence right
it's the it's the aftermath of saying
defund the police man
the politicians get scared and they're
like all right all right let's let's
let's hold back because we don't want
like think about it after painting black
lives matter in the street
renaming the plaza and then saying i
want a battalion of jack boots marching
through the streets locking everything
down
people she would get roasted by the left
so she's like nope nope
and now she's gonna get roasted by the
left no matter what but she was already
being roasted by the left when she went
out of her way she made sure that the
street
said black lives matter there was
another argument because they wanted
more she didn't want to give it
to them but we have some somebody put
defund the police next to it yeah and
they like washed it off
yeah and then some people are being
charged with hate crimes for for
putting out you know similar messages
but in a different kind of political
uh understanding but another thing to
really kind of
we really kind of really think here
along the lines of everything that
that's unfolding we have to understand
this is extremely
political when we have someone in a
prosecutor's office when we have someone
appointed as attorney general
and we have george soros giving them
millions of dollars there's a reason
he's investing so much money because
you not only get political favors but
you're able to kind of sweep the
landscape of our society
in ways that laws can't because when you
choose how you to enforce laws and this
is
the selective enforcement of it to the
highest degree when you see it
done this way it is ah stunning to see
what they could get away with you know
what's funny uh
shu on head posted his tweet where she
was like
it's a screenshot of parlor being
removed and she said rightos
this is what bezos has taken from you
let's redistribute his wealth as
like revenge or whatever and i i just
thought it was really funny and i'm like
i'm okay with this
i look i'm not really okay with the idea
of like seizing the wealth of everybody
and just spreading it around
there's a problem with corporate power
and government power when it exceeds
certain levels
but when you have someone like bezos who
has so much money
and mckenzie basis specifically putting
billions of dollars
into left-wing political causes it's
creating instability
so there's certainly something to
complain about there but i think it's
funny you bring up you know the
influence people get when they buy
politicians
which they basically do and there's
really no like i don't know if there's a
way we actually stop that process
but there is i think a left and the
right like left and right could come
together on this
and be like yo these people are
subverting our institutions and that's a
problem
well you also speaking of parlor you'll
you'll also never
guess the washington post
put out uh the editorial board put out
an opinion piece
uh about parlor you'll you'll never
guess what their opinion was
it's a good thing it was it was a good
thing yeah it was a good thing
our boss did the right thing basically
yeah right right yeah we're seeing
because amazon
uh bet jepez owns the washington post
well we're seeing a lot of flip-flopping
let's be honest here we're seeing a lot
of people flip from their original ideas
of defunding to police
to now the police are great and actually
and there's even some individuals
arguing that ashley babbitt deserved it
that's the that's the laugh those people
are sick yes and when you're making
arguments like that
after having months of protest against
the police and now you're supporting the
police you
really have to start asking yourself
what's going on here and these
flip-flops happen
not just within the left they happen
within the right in some instances but
right now we are seeing this kind of
shifting of of basic
kind of virtues overnight because of
political power
because of wanting your side to win
because of gang affiliation which is
more important than the truth to many
people
let me say something george floyd should
not have died
brenda taylor should not have died
ashley babbitt should not have died
it is a tragedy when any person loses
their life
you know i was saying it earlier i don't
care if you committed a crime
you know i don't want you to die i
understand their circumstances where
someone could be violent and dangerous
and only in the process of trying to
preserve life do we
end someone else's life that's
self-defense that's why that's why we
allow that as a
as a defense in court or as a reason not
to prosecute somebody but to see
antifa say that a person who has shot
an unarmed person shot by a cop deserved
it
wow talk about the utmost
hypocrisy now listen when i saw those
conservatives
throwing the blue lives matter on the
ground and stomping on it that to me
looked more like
anger and kind of a realization as to
what they were experiencing
and it was it was for for a lot of the
the conservatives who were you know
being
basically shut down by these cops
they've never had this happen before
because conservatives don't protest for
the most part
so to them it was kind of like this new
experience where they were like dude are
you kidding me this is ridiculous what
they're doing
so they stomped on that flag that's not
hypocrisy that's a change of opinion
to an extent i can respect antifa
changing their opinion if their opinion
was consistent
they're saying an unarmed woman who was
shot by a cop deserved it
okay all right so the guy with the taser
the shooting of cops that's you know
they're saying that the fascist us
government killing an unarmed woman
is justified antifa defending
what they what they claim to be fascists
well i love it we're going into a very
scary time where
policies no longer matter and only power
matters
and when you go towards this this
particular instant of where we're at
right now
we're going to see people leveraging
that power and trying to use that power
to try to hurt
their political opposition and and i
think that's where we are right now with
people trying to take advantage
and and escalating threats and and
fear-mongering about them to to really
rattle the
their base to support this kind of
emergency takeover of civil liberties
because that's historically what always
happens you know regarding ashley
babbitt
i i don't support i'm not glad she's
dead but they
she was climbing through a window into a
sensitive area of the capitol building
with a few uh armed guards that were
terrified for their lives and probably
charged to protect
things and people in there did you see
she had a footage she had a backpack on
so she got a bomb in that and that's
probably what went through their mind
when they saw it i i think they had
i think what are you gonna you're
supposed to defend the captain he
couldn't see her
no that's right she stuck her head up
there's police officers behind her
i know there's listen i'll say this i
don't think that officer should be
criminally
charged he it's his job to defend the
capital he's got politicians inside
and people were breaking the glass and
trying to break in and she pops up and
he fired
we can have it we can have a discussion
about administrative procedure due to
the fact that he fired on a person maybe
he fired too soon maybe he should have
waited maybe it was the right thing we
don't we can have the discussion okay
no criminal charges in my opinion
because yeah you you break your way into
the capitol
she may have been part of the group that
they opened the door for we have no idea
maybe she was part of the group that
shoved their way in
but you have an unarmed person and a
bunch of bewildered and doting people
who
many of whom didn't know what was going
on like that old grandma lady waving a
little flag coming right she clearly had
no idea what's happening
so so for this woman to get shot it's
tragic
i wish it didn't happen i don't blame
the cop i don't we saw criminal charges
for less for officers
uh right before so which is also
important to bring up and and i mean
there should be an entire investigation
into what happened and
there should be a jury deciding what
what should happen from here but i i
don't think you're right ian
that's just my opinion i mean it's
remember again you're
it's this is so different because it's
on a federal level
yeah uh these people are not elected
these
you know the the uh attorney general
uh is not elected uh unlike say
keith ellison in minnesota he was
elected
you know uh the the the the woman from
st louis
uh with the uh the the mccluskies yeah
right
elected and again george soros stuff so
that's
it it's it's entirely different scenario
and it's in its
in in a way it's it's scarier on the
state level
because at least in the federal level
there's
well there's there should be less bias
but you know it
it it depends on who you pick that's why
this part of this private police
conversation starts just freaking me out
we have a lot of people in here that are
like and cap to the extreme where it's
like no
no public service we want private police
only like a private policeman can shoot
you dead
well well it depends i mean if you make
the argument for detroit
detroit implemented private police and
they had positive results because of
that
uh and and you know you really get into
a big argument here that
it's kind of taken away from the kind of
conversation because there's still
uh just so many other things that we
could delve into but i understand both
sides of the argument here we do have
some breaking news though
trump has declared a state of emergency
in dc ahead of biden's inauguration
it's quite a simple story it's really
just donald trump approved it they they
said they want to declare a state of
emergency in dc there's threats against
the inauguration trump says
yes so it'll be interesting to see what
happens in the next uh
nine days or so they're saying armed
armed protestant capitals
uh armed protests in dc who knows what
is this trump's first statement
since that incident no no no he released
that twitter statement but other than
that
i mean people are waiting and i've been
there
there's been some weird stuff going on
yeah like i hear people like there's too
many conspiracy theories
you know i hear trump is going to give a
presentation and then he cancels it and
the state department thing pops up do
you guys see this no yeah with the state
department
claimed that trump's term had ended
today
or whatever or was going to end today
and mike pence's as well
and now they're saying it's like a rogue
employee i guess let's just we'll just
we have this one planned for later but
let's just we'll jump straight to this
one check this out from buzzfeed
a disgruntled employee changed the state
department's website to say
that trump's term ends today sources say
secretary of state mike pompeo is
launching an investigation after
biographical pages for the president and
vice president were changed monday
i don't i don't buy the story everybody
started sharing the state.gov
biography of trump that it said donald
trump's term ended and then
the current date plus like a couple of
hours it seemed like
some kind of basic script to just say
you know donald trump's term ended and
then
display time you know what i mean so
that no matter what happened every time
someone went to it it would show them
the current time based on like utc time
zone or something that's what it seemed
like
so i don't know exactly what happened
but this thing was a rogue employee
perhaps
buzzfeed says a disgruntled employee at
the state department changed the
biography biographies of president trump
and vice president mike pence
to say their term was coming to an end
on monday
nine days before the president-elect joe
biden is to be sworn in
two current serving diplomats with
knowledge of the situation told buzzfeed
news
the changes of the state department's
website come days after trump incited a
deadly insurrection okay we get it
buzzfeed
the president's biography was changed to
read donald j trump's term ended on
2020 2021 011 1949
the vice president said 1944-22 the time
stamp on trump's page changed multiple
times
before both pages were removed around 3
50 p.m and replaced with a 404
reading we're sorry this site is
currently experiencing technical
difficulties
please try again in a few moments one of
the diplomats said that secretary of
state mike pompeo has ordered an
internal investigation into the matter
beginning with interns and employees
leaving the state department this week
and next
ahead of the transition to the biden
administration so this is what it looked
like
right here it says donald j trump trump
trump's uh donald j
trump's term ended and the date and then
you can see for pens it was very very
similar
you know my responses when i saw this
right through jill
believe it or not straight to jail
whoever did this needs to get locked up
no joke charges
because we're at a time we're extremely
vulnerable
okay this country is going through
serious turmoil nancy pelosi
i'm not here to play games i know that
what i'm about to say is
is a strong statement but nancy pelosi
according to pen
the joint chiefs of pentagon officials
asked them to stage a military coup
and we can argue she didn't know what
she was asking for and that's fine
but it needs to be said pelosi went to
the pentagon to the joint chiefs and
said
do not obey lawful orders from trump in
certain circumstances incompetence is
not a defense
if she didn't know she was doing she was
still doing it and and and the argument
i give is she's been in congress for 50
000 years i mean of course of course she
she would know she was in like dinosaur
congress
uh yeah so she went to the pentagon and
said if trump gives you orders to like
start a war or fire nukes or whatever
disobey them and they said that would
amount to a military
coup they cannot remove the president
from the chain of the chain of command
he is the commander-in-chief why isn't
that being said
more of so anyway look the point is
considering this state we are in
with these kind of things happening now
would be the worst possible time for
hackers to break in
to mess with our country to start a war
or to come at us
and then some dumb intern or whatever
was like make a joke about troop
resigning
and now you get people panicking how
many what if people like
you've got people on edge we had just
people we peop we just had people storm
the us capital
this is not the time for jokes so that's
why i don't know if i believe it
because a lot of people were worried
this was a hack some kind of hack that
went in and they and they added this or
whatever but either way
could you imagine what would happen if
people around the country saw that
message
we no longer have a president no
statement no knowledge i remember when
twitter got hacked
the associated press got hacked by the
syrian electronic army to
put out a tweet from from the ap saying
that obama has been injured
and we lost like four billion dollars in
stock value
as soon as it happened and then as soon
as they corrected it it shot back up
but uh but uh only a 90 recovery
these kinds of things aren't jokes
whoever did this should get
the book and the book shelf then adam
but there
they were probably an obama hold over
and uh and in how many more days is joe
biden
they're probably going to get the medal
of freedom yeah i mean that's you know i
mean i
i no i i agree i mean they they should
be i don't think they should go to jail
i think they should just
be fired no you should just be you don't
look and i i i don't know what happened
like did anybody go into like uh
the way back machine and see what this
thing looks like because was that
was that time was that time stamp there
and all they did was just add some htl
html saying that his term is over like
right now
so at a certain point in the way in the
archives there's nothing it wasn't there
someone placed it there it seems like
around the end of december to have like
the current date or something
okay for whatever reason we don't know
why the date was changing but there are
versions from from december whoever did
this
in my opinion was broke into these
systems is
you no one was granted authorization to
claim trump was removed from office or
resigned
that's that's serious that's that's not
shutting down his twitter account
that's telling everyone in this country
the president's gone well it's only
telling people
that they're going to that website i i i
do i think
they should.gov do i think they should
be punished yes
but what's but what's the the state of
the crime the state department website
yeah but what's the crime well the the
actual statutory crime is the
violation of the computer fraud and
abuse act unauthorized access to a
computer server
for which i think the minimum is like 25
years considering it was the state
department
that's serious i'm not okay with these
people playing games right now man
we just had five we have five people die
right okay we've got people
freaking out in this country we've got
dramatic escalation in in every
political uh
arena censorship is going through the
roof calls for the expulsion of
republicans
for some dumb employee joke but here's
not but
my my my point is does anybody believe
it
no believe that it was a rogue employee
no no does anybody believe that
that oh my god i just saw this time
stamp but oh that means the president
yes yes nobody's believing because
trump is still in office no so where's
trump been he's not given a public
statement
and you know what i was hearing because
look listen i follow
as much as i can from all of these
different tribes i follow the mainstream
media leftists and the democrats and
republicans
and i listen to what the lefty you know
conspiracy people and the right wing are
there are left-wing people i saw posting
on facebook
saying trump was supposed to give a
speech
and then this website pops up announcing
he's resigned and now his speech was
canceled
they believed it they did
look man regular people that look
imagine that little old lady in the
capital you saw that picture of the
granny waving a little flag
that lady has no idea what's going on
i'm not trying to be mean but come on
she was confused and bewildered like joe
biden
and she sees on the website trump is no
longer president she's gonna
believe that and and look it's not even
about whether or not people believe it
for the most part it's about the fact
that somebody
because they were an angry trump
derangement syndrome [ __ ]
broke into a system exposing a
vulnerability in our in our
state department like dude we're on
we're on edge so much
we can't we can't we can't do this man
well i'm not saying that i'm look i'm
trying to be objective here i'm
this person should be punished yes do i
think that the that the people
that had nothing to do with the murder
be charged with felony murder no
so again i'm trying to you know i'm
trying to
i'm not saying lower the temperature i
agree i'm not saying give them 25 years
but i'm saying they should be given you
know some kind of charge it's got to be
you can't go into government systems and
do this and that's fine
you know i don't think that they should
go to jail for 25 years though that's
right
right ridiculous no no no no no right i
agree joe biden will pardon
him anyway did you imagine joe biden
being like this patriot
who tried to remove donald trump to
build back better
we're going to pardon him first thing
i don't should be arrested i don't know
who it is if it was one person
i mean you could pull some out and be
this is the guy that did it and we don't
know if that's right either so
i'm going to say that this person who
did it probably
put it out there to say you know it's
like hey look there's this
thing look at look at this it's crazy
right you know
if you know i saw a tweet i think it was
from redhead libertarian i'm not
entirely sure so if i'm miscrediting you
but it was like that point when you
realize our systems are made of are
cobbled together with sticks and stones
that was
me oh that was you yeah as you tweeted i
said that our systems are pretty much
held together with toothpicks and
cobwebs like
also wooden cotton candy because there's
nothing one person can do this is
insanity
i didn't know you were the redhead
libertarian apparently i am but
think about what they've exposed with
this stupid joke
that some dumb rogue employee at the
state department
could break the whole thing think about
what that means
i wonder what else up there is fake
right now but it's everything i mean
look
look at all these holdovers from the
previous
eight years all the leaks where do you
think those leaks came from
trump not republicans you know it was
funny i i think uh
i'm going to miss credit whoever said
this so i'm not going to i'm not going
to credit anybody it was me
the one thing trump was famous for he
didn't do fire people
yeah he should have just fired people
and he didn't do it
no he no he did he you know he he fired
he didn't fire uh the right people he
hired and fired
well okay that's true yeah uh but but
you know
you can't it's it's very hard to fire
government employees we know this
right trump it's one thing that to fire
to hire and fire
jim mattis it's another thing to fire
some low-level
you know look at what andrew struck
you know i mean peter peter struck sorry
andrew struck andrew mckay you
and him yes thank you uh i had a long
train ride guys come on
yeah but you know even it was it was
hard to get rid of them too
i mean there was push back there right
of course so and and actually did
something
uh which i'm not saying that this state
department guy didn't do something
i just i just think you know this
person's anti-trump sure
you know going off half the government
right you go off of the previous
discussion we had
you know we're talking about arresting
people for murder whatever
i wouldn't be surprised if prosecutors
are like we're gonna bury them in books
like it's gonna it's gonna be an example
tenfold
and then with this they're like well it
was just a harmless
prank we all hate trump right because
the orange man is bad so sure
that sounds okay yeah i don't i don't
see um
i don't can can we go back to the
inauguration for a second um
you know i think secret service probably
has everything covered as far as
safety and you know the these things
happen you know once every four years
like clockwork
so i think they kind of have everything
that they need to do and plus but but
honestly
i do not understand why this
inauguration
is even taking place i mean fine yes
the ceremony of you know him being sworn
in that has to happen but
having uh sixteen hundred people
in stands in front of the capitol isn't
that a super spreader
plexiglass between all of them they're
gonna stand
so what i heard is that he's going to
put his hand on the sanitizer instead of
the
box
this is serious that in order to do it
what's going to happen is
once you arrive for the inauguration if
you're one of the attendees you wait in
line
they have you six feet apart and then
they have these uh
eight foot by uh three three by three by
eight cubes
like or not cubes like you know big big
chambers they lock you and made a
plexiglass and they both they padlock it
and they put you on a forklift and just
carry you in and put you down you can't
leave you're trapped inside
and you're banging and it's airtight and
there's no sound but then joe biden's
safe so
great you get this look you're like
no it's like you got everyone's gonna
die because you had me halfway
no look i think i think it's so
hypocritical
for him to be holding this thing and
there's also going to be
onlookers too and vibration just like
his win
when they're on election night the guys
celebrate the guy's been wanting to be
president since the 80s
so this is his moment right nothing is
not even coveted
is going to stop this dude's moment and
you know what and
he's not going to remember it and you
know what and you know what we're going
to hear in the evening i guarantee it
biden's inauguration was bigger than
trump's inauguration
crowd no no no no i'm sorry i'm sorry
what they're going to do is
they're going to say that based on
online numbers they're going to make the
streaming for this makes it the biggest
inauguration in history
even though when trump was getting
inaugurated they discounted the live
stream views
and said that it was smaller than
obama's right and then trump was like
but look at the live stream you know
the webinars were huge well the way that
well i mean look i
i've been i've been a big critic of sean
spicer and the way he came out and
and presented it was just the dumbest
way possible
just just set the tone for the entire
four years by coming out
first thing you do is like yelling at
all the reporters i want to sing a line
from alanis morris that's ironic about
the old man
but i don't want to say it because it
has to do with the president but i think
you understand the joke you know an old
man turned into eight he won he won the
presidency oh yeah
but i'll leave it i'll leave it at that
uh for those that have the song i guess
you know yeah i'm really curious how
they're going to be doing the
inauguration because again we see
joe biden as the kind of plexiglass
social distancing always wear a mask 100
days of masks are coming presidency
how are they going to do it with
everyone standing together behind him
uh how are they going to do it with that
i think i mean if they do it he's a he's
a gigantic hypocrite and he needs to be
called out but they will not because i'm
out on it and and that's what that's
what kills me
this double standard well one thing
already one thing already they have a
crap
ton of national guard they have a crap
town of troops
coming together mingling together and
again this is
also something that that has affected
small businesses
tremendously on such a severe level so
for them to pull this off it's really
going to be something and second of all
it's also interesting to see new york
governor andrew cuomo tweet today that
we need to open up
businesses so maybe when the biden
administration comes in maybe there's
going to be a
another kind of flip of policies where
kovit's going to be magically over
like trump said well we've always been
saying that yeah and
and it's and it's been a joke but well
but but then joe biden keeps saying it's
going to be
long dark winter and you know what if at
the inauguration like biden comes out
and he's got his arm around like two
young dudes wearing hawaiian shirts and
sunglasses
and he's kind of slumped over and he's
wearing sunglasses and a hat and they
like bring him up and like
his arms flopping and he flops onto the
bible i think there was a movie about it
yeah yeah
well there was there was also a great
political ad for it too did you know oh
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it was great yeah it was
awesome this is what we have
to try and win and like it's great yeah
it's good
fun uh i hope it goes off like normal
man i i you know whatever it is
if they're if they're hypocrites i
wouldn't be surprised it should be
canceled well they are hypocrites no it
should legit be
it should be the first zoom inauguration
and that's it
and and instead they're to have 16 the
stand holds 600 people
they're all going to be wearing masks
outside and you're like well
why could you do it there but you
couldn't do it in other
things like why were why were they
considered super spreaders and this
isn't well right and then with the crowd
and with because
you think you think the people are are
going to go yeah i'm just going to stay
home like no
people are going to come out and i think
partially because they want to say
we need to make this bigger than trust
yeah they're going to yeah
and they are hypocrites so i think you
might be right because again we have to
understand here especially on the topic
of small business
the same people who are arguing that you
need to shut down small business to
defeat kovid
are the ones who are screaming right now
that businesses could do whatever they
want
they could censor whoever they want
because they're big private corporate
entities that should be left alone
magically again a major shift in policy
that no one's calling out or
or addressing well so can you know
considering these double standards i
want to talk about this video that's
going viral we have the story from the
daily mail
quote they called me an effing terrorist
moment burly pro-trump protester saabs
at dc
airport after finding out he's been put
on a no-fly list i want to play this
video first
i'm not entirely sure that's true
there's no fly list but let's play so
you can you can
you can hear one of you but this is
so this is just a video right there's a
guy walking away you heard what he said
basically that quote they're calling me
an effing terrorist i heard that it
might actually be that he wouldn't wear
a mask
and people are assuming it has something
to do with what happened at the capitol
and that he's angry they're calling me a
terrorist because he's not wearing a
mask right
maybe but we know that alaska alaskan
airlines did put
14 people on the no fly list and there's
been some discussion around this
but man when i saw that video this is a
middle-aged guy he's burly he's not some
like dinky little you know scrawny
individual whiny little soy boy or
whatever you want to call it
he is a whiny big trump supporter
and so i wonder when you see this this
defeat
this desperation this exasperation
that's uh
i'm i'm actually kind of worried about
hearing the kind of emotion coming from
people because
you know i was thinking about just what
they teach you in terms of cornering
a scared animal right it might be a
rabbit but you back into a corner i
think will
attack you you know so you get a bunch
of trump supporters you put them on no
fly lists you beat them down
they've been defeated and now what
happens they go after them with the full
weight
the full force of the government
threatening you know oh maybe there'll
be felony murder charges for anybody who
was there next
maybe maybe now if you're a musician
we're going to kick you off your label
simply for listening to trump speak and
then going home
maybe we'll cancel your book deals we'll
kick you out of congress they are
beating down these people so hard you're
going to get a bunch of desperate
angry and and just exhausted individuals
who just don't care anymore
yeah and that's when it gets scary when
when you look at the history of the
no-fly list it came after yet another
emergency that the government
milked that of course was 9 11. and that
system was used and abused where people
with the same names
babies people who had nothing to do with
anyone or anything were literally told
that they couldn't fly
and the their way of having any regress
or any way to have any accountability or
get the name off of this no-fly list was
virtually impossible
this happened for many years so seeing
this now implemented politically
i mean if you're going to charge someone
charge someone what's the purpose of
banning them from flying home or being
home
or even just transporting or going from
place a to b
what's the point what's going on here we
need more information
if they did something wrong charge them
let's let's get this over with
stop messing with them and toying with
them and trying to also and i think
another reason they're doing this and
we're seeing a lot of videos of people
being arrested at airports is to set a
chilling effect it's to scare people
is to make people think well maybe if
i'm a trump supporter this is going to
happen to me as well
and that's that's something that should
be immediately called out because just
like the no fly list was used and abused
after 9 11
with muslims and other innocent people
it's being it's going to be used and
abused
with the new kind of patriarch 2.0 that
they're proposing
that they're going to be instituting and
yet again government's going to be
exploiting another
tragedy another emergency for powers
that they will never give back
and this is the double standard i have
two points to make the
the first point is you have governor
ralph north
ralph uh northam you have a
bird what what is his uh you know the
former
kkk guy right uh robert bird
yeah robert yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah was pictured
with those guys
those people are allowed to redeem
themselves those people
are allowed to to uh
change their their thinking on all these
things right
they're allowed to be redeemed because
they have a d next to their name
all right but when you have when you
have a man who
i i again context is everything here
yeah we don't know if it
had to do with a mask or or whatever
right
but if you're if you're just a normal
person
who likes trump has a trump hat and then
somebody says suddenly
oh you're you're a bad person we're
gonna fire you from your job
we're going to delete your your facebook
account
we're going to uh get you fired we're
going to put you on no fly list
now let's say that that person is a
racist right
and all those things happen does them
getting fired and getting basically
canceled
make them less racist or more racist do
you think they're going to become
more racist they're going to become more
angry right
and the same thing with with this poor
trump supporter i mean that just hearing
that audio
and not knowing the whole context it's
heartbreaking
that that man is in pain yeah and we
don't know why
and if it's something stupid just like
like ariel pink
the the record art the musician who just
went to a trump rally he likes trump
there's things you
you're there's things you're allowed to
like trump for well not anymore because
if you do
you're labeled all these things abraham
accords completely racist
you know what i mean he's he did some
great things
you know when you talk about um uh
the the opportunity zones those are good
things
right but then you know you you can say
look
it's like ben shapiro says there's good
trump and there's bad trump when
when trump does good things we praise
him for when he does bad things
we go after him for it and i agree 100
and we should do that
to biden yeah but but just going after
people just
just trying to completely ruin their
lives just because
they like a guy who's who's absolutely
flawed is
incredibly scary think about where we go
in the next several years
and this is what i think republicans are
too stupid to realize mitch mcconnell
talk about dumb
does what do you think's going to happen
in 2024 when any republican tries
running any any one of them
no matter who it is they're going to
scream nutsy
and they're going to say it's trump 2.0
no matter what they called bush
a nazi i remember seeing the protest
signs it is
what was is it true that they've equated
like every republican
candidate going back like 40 50 years
they've
he's been called a nazi or a fascist oh
yeah they called they called george bush
a nazi they called ronald reagan a nazi
right right ronald reagan a nazi so
you know spare me your indignation
democrats because it's all the game
well you look at how bad things are now
come
2024 the the republican candidate is not
going to stand a chance
they're going to be completely
obliterated it'll be it'll be trump
the fake news and hoaxes about trump
tenfold it depends
hmm well he well it depends i mean we're
only looking i'm sorry we're only
looking at we're
we're we're looking at it from like one
angle
which is biden's popular now biden won
and then whoever runs in 2024 you know
uh
is going to be running against him maybe
not because
because first of all do you think that
joe biden
is going to be campaigning for a second
term he didn't campaign
this time around right but he's not
going to but he's not going to have an
excuse unless there's
like another global pandemic all right
and and and if he steps down
anybody could beat harris i tim could be
here and
well tim tim's definitely a smarter guy
than you know and better
you know a better skater you know well
i'm glad i agree
mainly because when you control the
institutions of information
mainstream media social media you pretty
much control what people can and cannot
hear
that's unlimited power that essentially
sets them in
a position that can't be challenged you
think you don't think that people
are gonna see what's happening right now
and totally be motivated how will they
see what's happening now
when the mainstream media is advocating
for all forms of competition to be
removed
once big tech companies are removing
these videos people who had photos from
the capital not even like
like from dc not even the capital are
having those photos removed
memes making fun of this year are being
removed sure
okay but but as he tried banning memes
did you hear this
yes that was a lot but as far as policy
goes
you're going to have you're going to
have all these states that are going to
be
uh their their their citizens are going
to be freaking out
about second amendment rights because uh
when kamala was running first she said
she was going to do a
an executive order about about guns and
it's like joe biden just like no you
can't do that
then she said well i'm going to put let
i want congress to bring up legislation
in the first
hundred days and if they don't then i'm
going to do this right so
with a with congress in democratic
control
now you can see these things happen you
can see
you can see uh a push for
there there's a push forward for um
getting rid of the electoral college
there's a push for puerto rico and
uh washington dc to become a state yeah
i don't know about guam but i mean they
might as well
two more senators why not let's have six
senators right so all these things are
gonna happen and people are gonna be
like whether or not they can tweet about
it or parlay about it i don't i don't
know if that's the term that is the term
is it really they can parlay about it
but people are people are going to be
upset and you're going to be mobilized
and 2022 remember this warnock
raphael warnock the the superhero
sounding uh
yes he do you know do you know when his
term is up
20 22 yeah because he's a special he
doesn't he doesn't get a full term
because he's
he's uh finishing out johnny isaacson's
term
so maybe georgia will get it together
in two years right and then
look the the people didn't turn out it
was a turnout problem as michael tracy
said
the left liberal monoculture is merging
with the state
so when you look at the suppression from
big tech
let's let's let's before yeah when you
look at this oppression
uh from the democrats calling and
advocating for the expulsion of
republicans
like i don't i don't see how we we come
back to this point
when af after they've already had
control of everything you know what i
mean like
part of the reason they lost in georgia
was stacey abrams getting this consent
decree from the governor
a democrat filed a suit they had a
consent decree
it changed the rules without the state
legislature and other rules are changed
and it heavily favors
democrats and it's and again turnout did
affect
republicans but do you think republicans
are going to get more organized as the
tools for organization are stripped away
well we didn't have
i i think that maybe uh
people are going to be turning to you
know alternate ways to
mobilize and communicate by no by email
just you know people they banned trump's
email list that
well okay that's fine but smoking
you can't you can't do it to everybody
right i mean they can
if you put together an email list
they'll just see
google will be like this person is doing
an email list he's a fascist
but nothing about email you could you
could export your emails and actually
have a physical copy of them and move
them to another server that might take
it down
but another thing that i think
personally will happen i think things
will spiral out of control
and this kind of cycle of violence is
going to continue i don't want it
to but i believe that's going to happen
because all the ingredients that created
this situation
they're being added instead of
subtracting from this
cycle and it's only going to get worse
and it's only going to keep spiraling
out of control and i don't want it to
happen
i've been warning people you've been
warning people and and all the signs are
on the wall that this is going to lead
to a crazier i mean with the no fly list
what is that going to achieve other than
a chilling effect
other than scaring people and creating
more people on the fringe now this
started
just let's talk about the merits here
because this was talked about
by a flight attendant unit but now it's
being taken up
by house democrats that are talking with
homeland security in special committee
meetings
and and according to some people this
has already been instituted
we're seeing a lot of people being
arrested we're seeing a lot of people
crying
we're gonna see a lot of people who were
milling around didn't do anything bad up
bad caught up in it punished and then
essentially even radicalized even more i
don't want that
to happen there are some bad actors they
do deserve to be dealt with
but when you're dealing with average
people when you're setting up a chilling
effect
when you're censoring people and
stopping them from having speech
you're not showing you have the moral
high ground because when you have the
moral high ground
when you have something that you think
you're you're better or good at
you let that speak for itself you don't
need to squash any kind of dissenting
voices against that
with that kind of authoritarianism with
that kind of unlimited
unchecked power we are truly entering a
time
where they're not going to be on they're
not going to be checked
and they're going to use that power for
uh
for their political enemies i have to
stop you okay i have to tell you
that these people were monsters and and
this this next image you're going to see
this person
needs to be placed on the no-fly list
look at this look at this
shocking image of a little old lady
smiling
bewildered we're holding her little
she's holding a little thermos
and she's holding a little american flag
i'm sorry man i'm not trying to be mean
to her but she clearly has no idea
what's going on
and then they're like it was an
insurrection yeah i mean there was a
group of people that were bashing cops
and
by all means charge them and there were
some doting
old women who were confused and the cops
open the doors and they're like waving
little flags as they walk in like
there were i mean i i think it depends
on where you know if you were breaking
windows and and
going in that way yeah you're probably
going to be
uh met with some kind of force but if
you're like grandma's like oh here let
me hold the door open for you miss
open the door yeah and and it's like and
there were people taking selfies i love
on twitter the indignation like
they were taking selfies that cop got
suspended the cop who took the selfie
but like
what was it what was this crime like if
there was exactly if there was like one
side of the building where it's like
that that building's supposed to be open
right i don't know about the i don't
know i don't know about the capitol
building the
had layers chambers um that day making
sure people couldn't walk right but
maybe not the house floor but but there
were definitely there were definitely
some mixed
there was definitely some
miscommunication because some people
were opening doors others were
trying to hold them shut so there's and
well this is where it gets scary
are they gonna take so so you have a
video where the doors are opened and the
cops are just standing there
yeah and one of the cops says something
to the effect of disagree with it
but agree with your right to protest i
don't know if he says you can disagree
with it
but i agree with right to protest or i
disagree with it i'm not sure exactly
what he says
there's been different quotes from
different people but there are a bunch
of people
just walking you know slowly and
like your little flags and then the cops
are just standing there and they're like
nodding and walking within the ropes
yep staying within the ropes as they
walk through and then there were some
people that smashed that bookcase with
like that famous literature that was on
it
yeah sure i'm so sure that there was
like women's historical literature on
that well and that was
one bookcase i don't buy it i think that
got knocked over because they broke the
window to get in
because yeah and then they burned up the
muscle and it probably knocked it over
but you know to get into those buildings
though you
you do need to go through security right
you do need to uh you know
i went a year and a half ago and and you
know it's it's not like the toughest
security ever
but they you know they they wand you and
they check your bags and stuff they
clearly we're not doing that
i'm sure you you saw what aoc said about
it something like we're seconds away
from half of congress being assassinated
yeah
oh and and then by this lady pull it up
again she was coming for aoc
the american flag was actually an
assassin's blade scared
and her little thermos was actually a
spy
uh device for releasing there's a bomb
in it true story
uh but but i asked bombs man let's be
real it was dangerous stuff going on but
who knows
who knows where those bombs came from
that's true right there's a video of
some dude dropping them
okay or like walking up well afc saying
that trump said
to storm the house she said that she
said trump said to storm the house
yeah so or or you know i'm paraphrasing
but she said that trump said the storm
you know to go inside and go on the
house where he never said that
no he he said let's go to the capitol
and and
cheer for politicians and cheer and not
cheer for others or something like that
no he he wanted them to like he wanted
the process to play out
he wanted his hearing finally and the
trump supporters went and shut that down
i love the yeah thanks guys you had the
live streamers like trump's going to be
happy with us oh he's going to be happy
that you disrupted the one time
finally on cnn they would air complaints
and evidence and uh and wow it was the
one
thing that we had and it ruined it it
was the
one thing that's all we had left
and you guys and you guys screwed up
thank you so much this is why i said
this is why i said the last time i was
here that these protest
yes the pro i said that protests don't
do anything i was wrong
protests are only have a negative effect
to the people that are protesting
right uh i actually had people go oh no
the protest just
yeah it it just set the tone for the
next four years
trump terrorists trumpism everything
they needed
everything they've been begging for
they've been sitting in their room lying
awake at night under their covers their
flashlight
wishing just something would happen so
they could prove
everything they said was true for we've
been we've been expecting this for the
last four years
mayor bowser remember that time magazine
was time magazine cover of all the angry
trump supporters yelling and it was like
what happens if trump loses
they gave them everything they've been
asking for for four years
trump supporters weren't rioting you
know they weren't smashing windows and
screaming and setting fires no
and they kept saying trump supporters
were dangerous and white supremacy and
the far right and all this
and then finally just before trump
leaves
they had to make sure they left the
administration with they left the
incoming administration
that one day to make all of those past
four years come true
it was it was almost like they're you
know it was almost like they were saying
you know maybe maybe blm had a point
with their well yeah and now let's let's
just
why don't why don't we uh kind of co-op
some of their methods and ideas
louie go help us louis gohmert said this
when his lawsuit was kicked out right he
said and the message is you have to be
as violent as black lives matter or
antifa
now the funny thing about that is that
all of a sudden i saw these lefties
these journalists being
like oh no he's inciting violence and
i'm like
but i thought those were peaceful
protests right if they're as
violent as the peaceful protest they too
would be peaceful no
and of course there's all the articles
uh the side-by-side articles like
back from the summer it's like uh you
know violence does have its place and
then they're like you know
now in 2021 it's like violence is never
the answer
have you have you guys seen the most
recent ryan long skit
where
this year we have to admit it i mean
there's even a compilation video of all
the news organizations of all the kind
of left-wing thought thinkers being like
yes we have to excuse it
the ends justify the means and we were
calling it out and it needs to be called
that whether it's from the left or from
the right it doesn't matter
whenever you invoke violence politically
everyone
loses we're all losing right now and
we're going to lose a lot more unless
people heed
the warnings that we're sending out
there and other people are sending out
there because again
one thing we need to also understand
here on this larger point
it's only going to get worse from here i
don't want it to
we have to do everything in our power to
try to prevent it and we're in for
a hell of a 2021. let's talk about
probably one of the craziest
maybe stupidest things the the left
faction that billionaires could have
done and it's the
it's the nominee joe biden sorry i mean
it seemed to
work out for him so far but we'll see
how it plays out check this out
parlor is suing amazon for suspending
app from cloud service claims antitrust
violation and breach of contract
parlor is seeking temporary relief after
after being blackballed by amazon web
services
a lot of people uh actually let me slow
down if you're not familiar parlor is
very much like twitter microblogging
platform where you get followers you can
make posts
and it was fast growing probably the
fastest
it was the number one app on itunes it
was removed by itunes and by apple and
google
it was then banned by amazon amazon web
services
the interesting thing a lot of people
said why would parlor
use amazon web services that's that's
such a dumb thing to do because of
course they'll ban you
that you need to find your own web you
know uh servers or web hosting
gab which is also a micro blogging
platform created their own hosting
system and they're building their own
infrastructure
so why would parlor use amazon in fact i
think it was the smartest thing they
could have done
because they had a contract with amazon
that if they're going to be terminated
they get 30 days
which is enough time for them to solve
their problems and move to a new you
know provider
but what happens now is twitter was also
using amazon
so what do we get in this lawsuit it's
fascinating parlor says
recently amazon signed a multi-year
hosting deal with twitter
then parlor is fast becoming the number
one
competition for twitter amazon
bans parlor so there's clearly a
conflict of interest and a benefit
for amazon's large massive and valuable
multi-year contract partner but here's
what they say
they claimed parlor wasn't enforcing
their rules as more specifically they
said we don't believe they will
enforce their rules there was i think
something like
60 i could be wrong there was a small
handful of posts that were inciting
violence
parlors said in the suit we remove them
all immediately because they violate our
rules
we do not allow incitement to violence
it is illegal
at the same time when amazon gave them
24
or so hours to to move their entire
platform violating breaching the
contract they had with them
hang mike pence was trending on twitter
and twitter did nothing
and amazon said nothing no public
statement no threats to twitter nothing
we're also hearing that they're trying
to claim that these people at the
capitol were organizing on parlor
glenn greenwald said that's not true
they organized on facebook
where was anyone going after facebook at
this point it should be obvious to
everybody what's going on
we've seen it before with patreon this
is really fascinating when patreon
banned a bunch of people they all
flocked to subscribe star
which was a competitor to patreon so
what happened
payment processing companies i think
like paypal and stripe immediately
severed
services to subscribe star which shows
what they're really trying to do is to
protect their monopolistic power in
silicon valley
there's no reason to ban parlor it was a
lie
it has nothing to do with threats they
just grab a few screenshots and they
post them but i tell you what i can go
on twitter right now and probably
probably find 10
000 death threats and violence and i'll
add one more of the layer
while this is going on i have personally
filed
several complaints to twitter over let's
just call it extremely abusive content
directed at me and they have not removed
it
can i now demand that amazon ban twitter
because i have been trying to get stuff
taken down that directly
threatens me and and and i'm to leave
out specific details as to what these
posts are
but they are some of the it's it's it's
bordering
i don't want to say too much i don't
want to reveal too much about what's
going on and why i'm having to report
people
but it's serious it's very serious
threats twitter won't take them down
at least with parlor there was you know
to sign up for a twitter account you you
just
you know have a fake email with parlor i
think you needed to
you know have your uh your phone number
and it was kyc
it's it's almost it's almost easier to
track down somebody like i'm sure that
if i i would
i'm pretty sure that if somebody if the
doj came
up to parlor and said look this person
is involved in terrorism
that they would go here here's all the
information we have
you know uh just well they said they
were cooperating with launch right
so so to to completely shut it down
and move those bad conversations
to you know to basically the the depths
of the internet
at least on parlor you could you could
see it
wide open right so this is you think
that
and you think the doj is going to go
after
amazon for anti-trust over this nope
hell
no right twitter harbors far leftists
who to this day have organized and
called directly for violence
no issues none well tim you know if you
don't like what amazon or google
is doing you should just build your own
cia connected monopoly multinational
corporation
you know why didn't i think of that yes
it's that simple it's that simple let me
we'll call it you want to get on it yeah
i'm in on it let's do it
no but we've got to make some points
here i mean when we look at you know the
history of something like twitter and
facebook there's
a long history of people publishing
information that hurt other individuals
so there's a long history of people
inciting violence whether it's the arab
spring or jihadis
or even the christ church town shooting
that was a live stream there was a
massacre live streamed
by a tech company that allowed the video
to go
everywhere so when we're talking about
let's hold these companies responsible
for what they're doing
that points back right at facebook that
points back right at twitter but it
essentially points back that no no we we
can't set up this kind of president
where people are responsible because of
what people do on
communication lines it's like the same
as charging at
t because some jihadi used their phone
or used their company
to talk to another jihadi that makes
absolutely no sense at all what if you
left someone a voicemail threatening
them
what would could you go after the
company for not deleting that voicemail
no but also i mean remember uh maybe in
the last two years there was a group of
of uh of current and former uh border
patrol agents
who had a facebook group and they were
all yes um
you know they were all sharing memes and
stuff and their i think pro publica
came out and showed like three all of
three examples
you know out of out of tens of thousands
of posts
where you know they were attacking aoc
and and they were vile and they were
they were bad and you know and
and that's fine but you can't you can't
then lump everybody
in right but then you you didn't go well
facebook was sharing that so let's
penalize facebook
uh what you know they went after the
group they went after some of the people
in it
i think some people probably got fired
but it's the same thing on parlor you
can't go
after an entire platform just because
there are a couple
you know bad apples right and they were
removing them it's the same excuse they
do with gab
they're like but they weren't really
enforcing their rules did you go on
there to make sure no
well they said they were enforcing them
but propublica said
but we found three people you know
it happens every single time build your
own i love it because now we're at the
point where it's like
every single vendor start your own legal
firm okay
they lost their lawyers because the the
the
as michael tracy said the left liberal
monoculture merging with the state
they have too much power they control
our lines of communication
they're controlling our commerce you
can't buy or trade
if they ban you from online uh payment
processing what do you do
i guess bitcoin and this this is where
this is where okay
if you know amazon's history you
probably know the amazon for
years didn't make a profit they didn't
make they
they didn't make a profit they also
weren't paying a lot in federal taxes
either
uh but that's you know totally legal
they were playing the long game they
were building their infrastructure they
were building warehouses all over the
place they were building these cloud
services
anytime netflix
goes offline it's amazon's fault it's
not netflix
it's because they're it's because
they're having issues with their with
their cloud services
so i can't remember what my point was
but
but but yeah everything about being a
gorilla yeah well we have to understand
that this censorship is absolutely
selective there's despots there's
dictators that are still allowed
to use twitter but president donald
trump can't and again we have to also
underscore that
there's a lot of international backlash
when we look at the market caps of
facebook and twitter they've been hit
but there also have been some leaders
some presidents coming out and speaking
out against this
including i'm really shocked by this
angela merkel the chancellor of germany
came out
and she spoke out about how problematic
it is for tech companies to have
so much power that they're able to
eliminate
a president from even having a voice so
look at your rocks
you're wrong no no you're wrong go ahead
angela merkel
doesn't matter the mexican president
also uh
released some very surprising statements
angela merkel
mexico how do you pronounce her
you know let's call the whole thing the
the statements by the mexican president
were really surprising because he went
even further than that attacking these
tech
companies as these arbitrators of of
truth and and lambasting them for for
such a move which
the mexican president is against angela
merkel is against the majority of people
are against because if you are the
morally superior voice
you don't need to silence other voices
you would debate you would argue you
would have a conversation with people
and you would prove your points it would
be
out there in the open you wouldn't need
to use the tools of totalitarianism
in order to just squash any ability for
for words to hit other people's ears
that's just insane
luke you're wrong okay go ahead angela
merkel oh my gosh
i saw that coming
but you're right about everything else
but you're completely correct yeah
well i didn't realize i didn't realize
that the mexican president was so based
he is well the mexican president is very
surprising with his latest actions he he
wants to grant julian's
assange asylum he he is calling out the
lockdown so it's he's not just a kind of
leftist figure he was previously
compared
as a bernie sanders but he's resisting a
lot of the bigger lockdowns
and he's saying no you can't just lock
down small businesses you can't lock
down communities you can't
destroy people's livelihoods all in the
name of security because
it's obviously a big joke so seeing this
happening in mexico
uh is is really surprising to say the
least i thought you're talking about
cuomo
no no yeah yeah cuomo did release the
statement today
como's always been for protecting small
businesses andrew cuomo recently came
out and said we can't keep this lockdown
going on for too much longer
the election we have to reopen and do it
safely and it's like
you know what's really funny is trump
trump said something like you know one
day will disappear
then there are a bunch of leftists who
are like all of these these people were
joking and mocking the left saying that
once the election was over
that covey would disappear and here we
are and it's like
january 6 just passed okay and now cuomo
has come out saying time to reopen yep
and buy it in two
but the opening is going to be done
based on your race according to joe
biden
so that's all another whole issue excuse
me tim cast is a minority-owned company
that's true yes
it is happy to work here that's right so
we get to reopen uh
not like we closed nobody really did
biden said it he's like we're going to
be prioritizing you know
native americans black asian latina
did he say latinx i know i don't know he
probably did
yeah and then he said and women and then
and then everyone else it's like
what is everyone else after that white
men white men where's the asians he
didn't even mention asia he didn't
know i thought he did not mention asians
what nope he didn't no he didn't say
asian wait
he probably didn't say asians he
probably said like pacific no islander
no he did it
[Music]
[Laughter]
but we've got some um uh my my friends
luke is about to
explode you're gonna watch his head
explode in real time i'm ready
the most egregious act of censorship
is quite possibly what's what's the
opposite of irony
like the epitome you know like it would
be like ironic if a fire truck's on fire
but what is it actually maybe it is kind
of ironic
ron paul getting censored on facebook
well okay the libertarian guy getting
censored
okay but i was getting opinions here i
was going no no no no
no i was i was going to mention it's
like you were like well why ron paul i
mean
why right well he's
do you remember who he endorsed for uh
the democratic candidate
for president who tulsi gabbard oh
boom that's right that's the problem
that's the problem
like of all the democrats to endorse
not her not the black sheep forget it
well this is the thing that's really
surprising here when you look at ron
paul he obviously his career is based on
calling out violations of people's
personal liberty
violations of government's abuse of
power he's a staunch
anti-war activist he he pretty much is
the main guy who calls for peace in the
middle east
but yet now he's being jump lumped in as
as
this kind of trump uh whitewashing this
kind of
trump censorship effort that's happening
here and i'm having a lot of people
respond
to this saying good get rid of his hate
speech and i'm like
what he's calling for peace in the
middle east what kind of hate speech are
you talking about he's talking about
personal responsibility and individual
liberty
how is that labeled as hate speech and
this is the response by blue check mark
people and i'm like okay okay
give me an example of this because
that's a very ignorant statement since
of course
it was ron paul that criticized donald
trump on many of his foreign policy
adventures
and then i i was called how dare you
call a woman ignorant this is the
there's there's the reply thing that's
going on in my twitter
you called a woman ignorant no i said
her mother
that was her response and i'm like look
i don't care what kind of junk you have
between your legs
give me an example of of how ron paul
hates speech her opinion is
automatically and i love yours and then
she called me a misogynist and i'm like
what does that have to do with anything
i don't care what thing you have between
your legs what matters here is is your
bigger allegation here and people are
jumping in
and even coming after me and people are
forgetting i criticized donald trump
like all the time and and now people are
lumping me in into this because i'm
standing up for ron paul who shouldn't
be lumped into this in the first place
so let me let me let me read the quote
from from ron paul
he said with no explanation other than
repeatedly going against our community
standards
facebook has blocked me from managing my
page
never have we received notice of
violating community standards in the
past and nowhere
in the offending post identified you
know you know what's funny about this
you know you listen you know what you'll
hear if you you turn on like ron paul
and the fed the gold standard sound
currencies
freedom liberty no wars it's not even
in like the things that ron paul's been
famous for and the things he talks about
for the most part his like
key focus isn't even a part of the
mainstream culture war
for the most part there's only one other
person i know of who constantly talks
about ending the federal
reserve and he's sitting in this room
right in front of me hello
oh ian's here yeah i got it from he sure
did yeah
ian's been very quiet tonight but people
are celebrating this as some kind of
cultural victory
against hate speech and i'm like what
are you talking about
about white supremacists about domestic
terrorism i'm like
you know the blue check marks are
bringing this up right now this woke mob
is bringing this up and and again
conflating so many important issues
as as i'm as i keep saying policies
don't matter power matters
and these people are power hungry and
going after individuals like ron paul
absolutely proves it to an objective
viewer who's just walking into this
situation who really wants to understand
maybe but you know look we're all uh old
people so you've got these 20-somethings
you know because there's one thing i
really i started to realize
when we had some of these younger lefty
guests on the show they were you know
when ron paul was coming into prominence
it's like 12 years ago
now the big ron paul era the ron paul
love revolution
so i'm you know we're all old enough to
have remembered that but these kids were
like ten
you know now they're 22 and they're like
yay communism
and they don't know who ron paul is at
all other than he was like a republican
so they're like yay ban the old white
man
and it's like he's for freedom i don't
know or care get rid of him
that's it fox news and cnn was attacking
him nonstop when he was running to be
president of the united states he was
the only one
standing up as a principled individual
against
this crazy aggressive american foreign
policy against the military-industrial
complex against the actual issues that
literally mattered and now he's being
lumped in into into magga and
rand paul's dad that's why well again
rand paul is not ron paul that the two
are very different they have very
different policies uh ron paul made sure
to always vote no no matter what it was
so you got to give someone like that you
know respect he was in there
and and he sent out you know uh he
worked with kucinich
yeah he worked out with dennis he worked
with denis kucinich cynthia mckinney a
lot of the kind of
old-school anti-establishment
representatives that were
not just republican not just democrat
but individuals that stood on principles
do we have any of those left uh that's
the
would you would you give credit to rand
paul for that partly
i don't like any politicians as you know
not even ron paul
well we have one for a couple more days
and that would be tulsi gabbard
yeah you know i mean she endorsed biden
yeah she did
did she did she endorsed biden
because allegedly bernie was a meanie
and bernie is a meanie i i've been
around bernie
throughout the kind of presidential
debate circuit and
at public events he's a mean guy barney
yeah he's like he's
well didn't you see that that
documentary about him where he wouldn't
shake the woman's hand
and he wouldn't pop the shoulder back
into place and he didn't want to drink
the two percent milk
no i don't yeah you know you you don't
know what that is you guys know what
that is right mm-hmm
the asset burn your enthusiasm on snow
yeah one of one of the only funny things
centered live they've got very few
really funny things a lot of their stuff
is really dry but
they did that famous you know they had
um what's the guys
larry david yeah playing bernie sanders
and he's like he wouldn't shake the
lady's hand because she coughed in her
hand you remember that right
you've never seen it uh i mean i've seen
i've seen the larry david
stuff i don't remember that particularly
i don't watch saturday night live viral
bernie video is hilarious
so he's like he won't put uh the only
milk they have for his coffee is two
percent
and so he's like i want whole milk and
so he goes out and then like
a woman crashes her car on her way to
vote for him and she's like pop my
shoulder and place like i'm not going to
do that
and he ends up losing by just that
amount of votes of the people he refused
to help
and then like that's the joke he loses
by two percent but
it was hilarious allegedly because of
interpersonal drama between bernie and
tulsi this is one of the reasons why
tulsi decided to endorse for joe biden
and i think
also i think she voted for him i don't
know well
i don't i don't know but i'll say i
think uh tulsi has tried to prevent the
fracturing and hyperpolarization
tried i'm not saying successful but in
the in
you know the last bit of her remaining
you know congressional term she's put
out some fairly moderate
liberal type policies pertaining to
cultural issues but she's also
come you know uh out against
you know like the the russian
investigation ended and she's like
that's it
that's right it's done like like let's
move on that's why they don't like her
well she's you know yeah she's she's a
progressive
but she's not she's not triggered she's
not
she's more she's very she's objective
she has principles she
there there's things that she will fight
for and fight to death for
but she's not she's not hyper partisan
and that's i would never she's voting
for her corporate establishment
but she's not hyper partisan and that's
why i like her that's why i respect her
how crazy is it that tulsi gabbard who
is
she i'm understanding she's for gun
control right it's like one of her one
of her positions
she's for increasing the minimum wage to
15 an hour
she opposes nuclear energy she is very
on the left
and they call her right wing they say
she was assigned republican at birth
and she goes on tucker carlson and she
goes on fox news
she is not on the right in any sense of
those words
but that's how insane the overton window
is right now people
even tulsi gabbard is right-wing people
only remember two things
about her uh she went to syria and met
with uh
bashar al-assad yep right even though
she had permission to do it
right it's like it's a callback joke to
a joe rogan episode
i don't think she's a toady but also the
second thing was she opposed gay
marriage
and it's like yeah well so did joe biden
and so did barack obama
so did hillary clinton but because
again she's she's like the outcast of
the dnc because she was
she was vetted for the dnc they were
like this is going to be
one of the next big stars and then she
started questioning the establishment
she was like
well we had 24 debates between
hillary and obama and now in 2016 cycle
we're gonna have
six yeah really we're gonna have that's
it and she went after kamala really hard
yes
when tucker carlson mispronounced her
name they said it was racist yeah i'm
just trying to help
you and when and when joe biden and when
joe biden uh
pronounced her name improperly and you
know it was just chalk it up to old man
he has a stutter or also also when he
said um
you know uh doug imhoff kamala's wife oh
my gosh
which uh you know i i i like that too i
mean that's the joke that everybody's
been making anyway
but you know it's still funny comeless
wife
joe biden oh man
well let's hope let's hope in two years
they the um
the republicans uh learned their lessons
uh from from the last no i'll tell you
what's gonna happen in two years
so they did win in the house in in the
state levels so which means they're
going to control
redistricting which will give them
massive advantages
in the next election that's a lot of
people don't realize isn't that isn't
that creepy
that it's not about your message it's
all just team
sports and because we went at the state
level now we're going to win at the
house level
and it's like ideas kind of irrelevant
just
oppose the other i guess but it's also
the census
you know thanks to thanks to uh krovet
and all these terrible
terrible policies you have states like
texas and florida which actually might
gain a gain
a congressional district california
might lose one california might lose two
and same and the same thing with um uh
with new york
they were they were they were expected
to lose one they might lose
three total three which it's
it's possible but there was always the
talk about uh
how if they were at least gonna lose one
and this is before
you know the pandemic that that uh aoc's
district
would basically they would just
eliminate it and swallow
like basically swallow it up between all
the other districts and then she would
have to either
run in in another district or just
decide that she's gonna run for senate
which is
going to happen one of the biggest
issues in the culture war split right
now
is trans issues you know you can see
that conservatives don't agree with the
idea of misgendering or they say there's
only two genders and the left clearly
disagrees
i i'm willing to bet that you give it
four maybe eight years and republicans
are going to be 100
on board with all of it i'm not kidding
i'm not trying to you know be bombastic
or anything i think they'll be 100 on
both all of it
completely and the left will be much
further in in the direction of
some new kind of you know issue
pertaining to
love or sexuality or identity itself how
much further can they go though like oh
they where
where will they be eight years other can
well like trans species what about like
cutting off your limbs
yes already body dysmorphia but then
what happens with
uh say the tulsi gabbard uh legislation
that she
uh introduced to protect to protect yeah
so do you do you think and are you
saying also that in eight years
like where does where does that go what
happens
if we look historically back at how uh
culture has shifted is there a reason to
believe the right will retake ground in
the coming eight years especially
considering the democrats just see
like took every you know every branch of
the federal government it's possible
because you can have
assuming they pack the supreme court not
only just that but also influencing
people through the algorithms and the
timelines
and what they've been showing through
social media manipulation hollywood
right right right right all the
subliminal listen listen listen you you
go watch a kids show
and see the things that are that are in
it these kids are going to grow up and
they're going to vote
and they are going to be even further
culturally
you know uh progressive than 20 year
olds today
and you're gonna get a bunch of i'll
tell you this is the funniest thing
these these lefties who are like 25
in 10 years they're going to be right
wing and then the new left is going to
be these kids they're having similar
conversations that that we had
and then we're going to find a lot of
these people now agreeing with us on
certain issues
but if you look what you got to do i'll
tell you something really creepy
i saw this post it was uh someone
tweeted at christopher ruffo
go on google and search for kids being
taught that they're white supremacists
take that same quote and put it in
duckduckgo and see the results
when you when you when you put it in
google it's like your kid is a white
supremacist how to teach your kid their
white supremacist you put it in
duckduckgo and it's news about how
schools are teaching this
so here's my prediction i see no reason
to believe the right is going to make
any cultural gains at all
they've never been in uh for whatever
reason
smart enough i guess or uh uh
understanding of
having an understanding of the game to
go after cultural institutions now the
daily wire is doing movies
and they have that new movie it's called
what's called run hide fight which looks
seriously intense it looks like i've
seen it is it good
it's solid it's solid it's very intense
and and after the
the last week or so uh
with everything going on it's very
stressful
uh like i'm i'm not being paid by the
daily word they sent me
they sent me a screener uh they sent
lauren chen a screener too
and and i was like uh and i remembered
i'm like i think i have something in my
inbox from their pr team
uh but it's it's a it's a solid movie as
thomas jane who yeah
the punisher yeah it has treat williams
who was in uh the substitute movies
right you know so um this this this girl
i cannot remember her name
this girl is like like her real name the
actor's name
zoe hull is her character name but the
the actress who place her is
badass she's she's really can we get
really good
can we get a screener and didn't the
punisher guy get cancelled because of
vocal culture as well
i don't think so maybe that's i don't
know but it's a great it's a great it's
it's
it's not like the greatest movie you're
ever going to see ben shapiro is
definitely hyping it up but
it is definitely it is definitely a
solid movie it's worth the watch
and what's your what's your what's your
score one out of 100 out of
oh god like uh like a round tomato score
yeah like a 79
80. yeah it's not it's not the look
there's
i don't want to
it's definitely worth watching the point
i'm trying to make is this may be one of
the first times there is a conservative
production
from for a piece of content that's
actually worth watching
yeah it was definitely worth the watch
what's that super religious netflix they
have
got flicks is that what it's called
that's what it's called
farmers only you know what it is because
they it's like
it's on the fox uh commercial like i see
that commercial on fox news all the time
that's like
yeah but yeah like the productions oh
watches that stuff it always looks rash
it looks cheap it looks like okay honey
can you
can can you get the kids camcorder i
want to like shoot something yeah
you know run hide fight
it's it is uh stylish it looks good
camera works great it doesn't look cheap
right it doesn't feel cheap
there's actually there is a scene though
where one of the guys is holding a gun
and it's a rubber gun
and it's bending and i could not take my
eyes off
couldn't they just get a replica what
are they doing well they did they had
some but
i guess they didn't have enough to go
around or i don't i don't know what what
it was
production-wise but i just see this this
guy's he's holding he's holding
it and the barrel's like like it's not
just pointing down but then it's
pointing to the right and i'm like oh my
come on you couldn't fix that there's
your easter egg well
it was a screener it was a screener so
they'll probably digitally no no
you don't think they'll fix it no no
it's not the movie's done they can they
can edit it digitally what do you mean
they they it's a screener
yeah they could of course uh you they
won't what if they didn't they wouldn't
they'll like cgi a gun from like fix it
bad 64.
anyway the point is that does make me
think that there is a potential for
media to start being produced that will
influence a younger generation
but they're still 10 years out from
actually getting any foothold in culture
well now that everything's streaming
right uh
yeah because you know this is you know
when you when you get the playstation
or the new xbox there's always like the
killer game it's like the game you have
to have
right there's not a lot of content
coming out other than
you know what's on disney plus like i
don't that wanda vision looks just
bizarre i don't know weird and i've no
interest in seeing that right
but i was so excited watching this that
the trailer is great for run
hide fight right and maybe
that like if there's something good like
the mandalorian
you know the mandalorians like it's kind
of like a must-see thing
right now if if if people are into that
kind of action movie and there aren't a
lot of action moves out right now
you know because movie theaters are
pretty much dead we can have that
conversation another time but
yeah uh but having something like the
killer app
you know of this movie you know to get
subs like go
go for it now another thing i kind of
wanted to bring up and talk to you guys
about is when you dominate culture
you have a lot of power and control and
i think you could be right too but i
think also there could be a kind of
reaction towards this because
if you look at culture especially in the
united states especially in the 1990s
it hasn't changed or progressed since
usually the 80s had
had its own unique culture the 70s the
60s they had their own hair
their own clothes their own music their
own kind of way of life their own kind
of
uh environment and and excitement about
those times
since the 90s we don't have any of them
that's not true i mean in my opinion
i don't i haven't seen a huge difference
between the 2000s the 2010s i don't see
a change in clothing i don't
see a change in hair i don't see a
change in music i see it all becoming
kind of repetitively the same or
i'm just becoming old you're probably
coming old okay so
you can look at the what are they called
the audi's that's what they refer to as
the
2000s the audi's and the 2010s and
there's distinct music that was popular
in the early 2000s that was prominent on
networks and on social platforms on
myspace and things like this
that aren't really that popular anymore
so each decade does still have
its shifting you know cultural trends
and everything like that
and maybe you just don't see it because
it's easy to look back at the 90s
and recognize that you know baggy
button-up shirt and like
i don't know stone double pilots and
stuff like that the 80s were weird man
yeah
everybody agrees yes 80s were weird what
was it like leopard print hot pink hot
pants
yeah what were they thinking while they
roller skated a lot of weird stuff
but for me for me nothing not much has
changed uh
that's just my opinion maybe i'm just
seeing it a lot of people a lot of
things do
you know a lot of things are cyclical
like back in the 80s camouflage pants
were a big deal and
you know then to me it's like they're
regurgitating everything especially with
movies
oh well i mean fashion definitely is i
do think
oh by by the way isabelle may that's the
girl who plays
okay and it's pure flicks
you're great and and i hope that you're
you have a great future because
oh i don't know though she did a daily
wire movie oh yeah uh
yeah i heard ben shapiro was a fascist
so um
one of those writers yeah the truth
you're probably right
right yeah yeah that sounds like that
sounds like ben shapiro yeah
that that silly little hat it's all a it
is a ruse yeah for sure it's disguised
how about how stupid you have to be to
think ben shapiro is all right it's the
most
insane thing ever he's
he's jewish he's a number one state of
that but also he's not
he's not cr like he's not edgy crazy
conservative
you know and what i like about very
mainstream what i like about ben
is that he he's you know he comes from a
has a law background right so that he
approaches
these things very differently than you
know most
uh pundits you know like mark levin you
know he's
he's all about you know constitutional
law so you see that
way but but ben but calling ben shapiro
radical which which
aoc has by the way called him
radical which is just mind-blowing like
this is how stupid she is
ben shapiro is so much more like
traditional conservative like a kind of
person
the kind of opinions we know and expect
and aoc is the radical with opinions
you'd be confused by
yeah and i i just mean like when aoc
comes in a lot of things she advocates
for you're kind of like
about what like what is it like bench
build comes in you're like oh he's a
conservative
heard this before it's you know very
very traditional conservative positions
and a lot of issues
aoc is like you know the green new deal
was not even about the environment it
was you know equity for college
and whatever equity equity bills and she
doesn't understand any of that she's a
sponge
right she but but one of those like
really cheap sponges that you
you know get at the supermarket where
like the little ones where you get them
wet and it's a dinosaur you know
it's not that's
[Laughter]
like she she's like a parrot she hear
she hears people say certain buzz words
certain things
certain things about equity and then she
tries to remember them and sometimes she
jumbles them up
but she knows how to tweet she doesn't
understand you know what she knows how
to do really well
is to clap in between words yes yeah
well look one one thing she has look
she's she has a brand
and no matter what happens with her
political career which isn't going
nowhere because
if if maxine waters can can hold a
political
uh house seat for for decades
aoc she's got that cover president
we've talked about this you don't think
she'll be president she'll run for
president she will not
she will not win the presidency i don't
know i think she cannot win
i think she's like trump most of her
support is outside of
the district that she supports as well
as her donation
it's it's like 99 it's like 98 99
of all of her donations come come from
outside of her district
because her district's poor it's it's
like a bunch it's a it's a
a big spanish immigrant community she's
like trump
she she what she's good at is not
politics
it's personality social media she does
not connect
with people and like she she went on a
on a a rant about that she went on a
rant about the electoral college saying
look at all this land that votes right
like she was driving across country
she does not care about any of those
people in any of those red states
not not one person if she doesn't have
any respect for them
same thing as anderson cooper talking
about you know people going back to the
olive garden
right she she does not connect with
those people she connects with the woke
crowd so
that's it i'll tell you why i think
you're right i agree
i'm damn right well think about it this
way
the reason why i think aoc was able to
win is that
normally the people who believe the
things she does
are fringe and they're all over the
country
so if you live in a town with let's say
you live in a block and there's 10
people
and you know four of them are
conservative
five of them are democrats you know are
like moderate democrat and one is a
radical socialist or democratic
socialist
that one person has no political
influence whatsoever no no power in on
that block
okay this is this is why aoc one
has won two elections let me make my
point
that one person can't influence the
block but aoc because of the internet
was able to create a network of all of
the different fringe elements in
different areas
and all that power got pulled into her
in her new york district
so whereas these fringe pockets of far
leftists in their areas don't hold power
together online they all send their
money to her which allows her to
overwhelm the district she's in
that happened after the the primary
election that right she she that's why
she has 12 million followers that's what
i'm saying okay but
but that that was after the fact first
but what i'm saying is that's why she
can't win
in a presidency that's what she has 12
million followers on twitter
yeah the reason why that won't translate
into
her actually winning is that those
aren't regular working-class americans
that's her brand people like her for her
brand but in her district
she she beat joe crowley because he
underestimated her
he was uh he was in the the office for
ten terms
yeah he was the fourth most powerful
uh democrat in the house for one reason
and one reason only
he was a great fundraiser right but aoc
came in
and just totally decimated him in a new
york one uh debate
and he didn't even show up for a second
debate he sent a proxy
so he basically completely
underestimated her
and you know she's the new young fresh
thing
you know with you know saying oh he's
he's establishment oh he's in the hands
he's in the pockets of
of uh big real estate you know all this
stuff
when she ran in the general
she didn't have any competition and the
same thing and the same thing happened
with uh with with her second election
she ran against michelle caruso cabrera
who was
an idiot she was one of the dumbest camp
she was one
she ran the one of the worst campaigns
i've ever seen
this woman might have had a little bit
of a chance i thought that she would be
smarter i was wrong
she's a dumb right imagine imagine being
beat by aoc
just imagine and also imagine being beat
by joe
biden right but yes yes yes but
here here's the thing about aoc is that
she plays to
[Music]
she's a character she's a kardashian
right that's where i put it
she's she's that kind of influence or
personality
when oh man you know one of the most
annoying things was when she was talking
to
what's the what's the director of ice
guy thomas homan
homan oh yeah yeah and she and she said
like
legal asylees are not criminals and then
he goes they violated subsection two
section three a of the
uniform immigration code the end of the
country illegally and i was like
it was just like okay i reclaimed my
time it was really annoying how she said
it
because it was meant to manipulate
emotionally yeah they are not
criminals like okay dude chill we're
having a hearing we want to have an
honest
i i can't stand that manipulative kind
of well that's what he does
so many so many congress people so many
people in congress do that and
senators and representatives like
but but she does it the radical left
is she in this country you know they
they sit down ahead of time and say
what are going to be what are the what
can we say
that's going to make the sound bites on
now this news
you know that's what at this point she
can just be like
here's the sound bite for now this news
and they'll just say oh it's aoc you
gotta run it but she has like five
subreddits dedicated to her that are
always on the top of reddit
and it's just like really dumb young
people who don't even understand what
she's saying
but i'll tell you this i can i can
summarize dunked on that guy
i can summarize aoc's campaign um
most of it there are some things i've
praised her for for sure she worked with
ted cruz they advocated for ending
lobbying like the lobbying pipeline
she's called out uh big tech for
surveillance mass surveillance
awesome stuff but for most of what i see
from her is this
yeah and it's like okay you snap back i
get it
that's great now about those amazon jobs
remember when she put her feet up like
amazon opening a marketing department
with like a
like a thousand employees compared to
the 40 000 or whatever employees in the
massive headquarters
and she like was smugly sitting there
like they came anyway and it's like
whatever i don't live in new york
anymore so i'm not going to complain
about it they vote for it you get what
you vote for
right they clearly want her and so look
she knows how to win she's one she's got
a lot of followers she's
you can you can criticize her you can
say she's not smart but she's certainly
got some kind of talent
well that she's doing she she has a
talent for
for celebrity and the brand that's right
she she does not have a talent
and listen whatsoever politically other
than she is
a great grandstanding she is a great
influencer a very talented one and only
a fool would deny it
oh no i i agree i agree um
but unfortunately actually maybe
fortunately
uh you know since she doesn't give money
to the d triple c
uh since she does actively try to
primary uh sitting city representatives
sitting democrats
um she is going to be shut out
by from a lot of things including uh you
know seeing
any of her legislation uh voted for on
the floor
yeah but you know to be honest we'll see
uh she'll be in for a long time
and nancy pelosi is not gonna be in for
what she's saying like two more like the
next one
that's the thing she's she is going to
be there for a long time and going to be
ineffective and you're going to be like
well what has she done for
perhaps oh well she's she's really
pretty you know like she's
my hair is great my question is who do
you think is worse pelosi or aoc
oh afc really oh yeah yeah i think
pelosi i think pelosi no no
look no like she's
pelosi's more effective i mean look look
what she did she was able
she was able to help derail the election
by by uh
but i'm not happy about that but like at
least
but that's her job that's what she's
supposed as house speaker she's supposed
to
she's supposed to totally screw with the
other side no
and trying she okay if that's what you
want you think it's a good thing
no no no i'm not saying it's a good
thing i think that she's
like who's a better person no no like or
who's the better who's better at their
job
he had to vote he had the vote for one
of him he had no choice for speaker
no no just like right now some guy comes
up and he's like vote or else and you're
like oh no and it's aoc it's policy
what'd you pick
if i wanted to see well i mean look i
just i wouldn't vote democrat
for in in in that way anthony pelosi
nancy pelosi is done
and i've i've defended pelosi in the
past because i thought
you know the squad was being ridiculous
and unreasonable and pelosi was pushing
back
but at this point pelosi is just
i'm just so sick of pelosi i'm just so
sick of the establishment
garbage crony i don't care about you i
lie i cheat and i steal
with matt you know i just don't like it
and at the very least
aoc has some kind of you know uh
argument for actually wanting to help
people not that it's very strong in my
opinion
but pelosi is just like she's this old
crone at the top of the tower looking
down with contempt at the people
i'm not gonna pretend like aoc is
perfect or anything like that
but i think pelosi is substantially
worse but you vote for pelosi because
you know
that she she's like the top fundraiser
in the democratic party
you vote for her because well first of
all she's in your district this is the
only reason why she wins
in in san francisco in in that area in
her district
because she's the most powerful person
in congress
right so of course you're going to vote
for her because your district difference
that power different argument
i'm saying that i like aoc
as kind of a disrupter in the democratic
party i don't like the crony corporate
establishment politics
and that's for similar reasons i like
trump for policy reasons trump was doing
with like
the abraham accords with middle eastern
withdrawal with critical race theory i
preferred him over someone like aoc
but in terms of disrupting the
establishment and you know a lot of
these crooked corporatist types
i prefer aoc but afc is not disrupting
anything she's
she's loud that's it i'll take it she
yeah but why would you but why would you
vote for somebody
that you know isn't going to get
anything done other than just be like a
loud person i wouldn't vote for her
well that was that was the if i had if
if i had no choice
and i had to pick between the two i'd
pick aoc over pelosi every day
okay fine if i thought you were talking
about
you know like if you're if you're a
democrat and you know if if it's for me
i would
i would vote for aoc because she's not
going to get anything done
and nancy pelosi like i would want to
derail nancy pelosi
right but if i'm a democrat in in a
district and those are my two choices
you go for pelosi every disagree for for
me you guys are
arguing over stinky butts like well this
one has a little bit less pimples well
this one has
nancy pelosi's uh she's you know i i
would prefer
a progressive populist over
a corporate establishment candidate the
problem is i think aoc is a careerist
and there are other progressives that i
would much prefer
uh to aoc or pelosi like if there was an
actual progressive lefty universal
healthcare and all that stuff like very
left
critical race theory and stuff i just i
i don't even agree with i'd prefer over
pelosi
but aoc is a careerist i don't think she
knows what she's talking about half the
time i think she
she wants followers and she wants fame
and attention
it's her career she's going to socially
climb and all that stuff pelosi is
exactly that
but establishment crooked ultra wealthy
twenty thousand dollar refrigerator full
of ice cream laughing at the poor
peasants
the old crone looking down for the tower
with contempt i mean i hate them both
but
it's you know what are you what are you
gonna do i mean again i didn't
vote for them i do not live in either
their districts
that's why aoc voted for pelosi to be
speaker right right
which is just you know um at least she
has principles we got to do super chats
because we got to do super jets but uh
good good good good debate i wonder what
the chat's thinking about aoc versus uh
pelosi you can press one
if you believe you can press two
if you believe pelosi is it's like thank
you i mean i hate both of them
don't get me wrong but i'm just saying
as far as effectiveness goes it's like
that tweet i put out where i said who do
you trust more
at the government or the mainstream
media and everyone's like they're ah
i don't want to pick either or press
three if you're sick of it all like me
smash that like button if you have not
already it seriously does help when you
give us a good thumbs up if you're
listening on the podcast leave us a good
review because it also really does help
and uh i forgot uh you know i should i
should announce this now for everybody
listening
timcast.com is up it's live members only
area is now in existence we have yet to
actually start producing so it's very
much the early stages we just went live
with the very new timcast.com which has
all the new podcast episodes
and we're going to have exclusive
members only content that will be
only available through the site for
paying members it's 10 bucks a month
but we're also going to be doing
physical events
at the studio limited ticket sales per
event when we do
and it'll be like first come first serve
so you'll get an email and everyone's
going to be sitting there refreshing
their phone and we're not going to know
we're not we're not going to plan out
events and like announce them
you know hey the event is this day
tickets will go on sale on this day it's
going to be one day i'll get an email
saying tickets are now on sale it's
going to be
like so far sounds where it's all you
know like very last minute
super last minute cool because we i i
don't know how you make it as fair as
possible
you know yeah so it's just randomly
doing it this is the highest super chats
yeah no no that was the thing too
because uh so again go to timcast.com
you can become a member you can log in
it's it's still very much i guess kind
of beta we just launched and so we're
gonna try and get things sorted and
fixed and
and smooth but one of the challenges was
we're like we have like higher tiers if
you want to donate a ton of money like
what do you get
and i was like maybe we set up a thing
where they can come to events and i
thought it was really crummy
that we would tell someone if you're too
poor you can't come and hang out that's
kind of messed up
so i was like we need to have it just to
be kind of like an email goes out and
it's first come first i mean i was
joking but but yeah no but it was a good
point because the question was like how
about if you give 100 bucks then you get
a ticket to events when i'm like nah
that's messed up
if someone needs to know people i'm too
lefty if someone can't afford it i don't
want to
exclude them you know we want people to
be able to come out but gotta be honest
it's gonna be like 20 tickets per event
and then we're gonna do online you know
we're gonna film we're gonna stream and
do shows
so again go to timecast.com become a
member we're gonna start putting up
members only content so what'll end up
happening is we do these shows with
these guests
we're gonna record special exclusive
like hangout chats after the show ends
and then put those up after the shows
and stuff like that so again check that
out smash that like button and now we
will read super chats
justin force says if the dems actually
expel
elected reps like cruz and hawley then
by what authority other than violence
does the federal government have the
right to govern and tax the states that
are now unrepresented
they can't expel them they can't no they
can't because
uh of the speech and debate clause in
the constitution they can basically say
anything they want on the house floor or
on the uh on the on the floor and you
know
they're not being incendiary they're
they're they can actually commit crimes
right like
so you could lie you could you could
call somebody you could
you could slander them and say that they
did something which they weren't
and you know like say uh debbie
wasserman schultz
calling ken cuccinelli uh a white
supremacist
right he couldn't do anything about it
couldn't do anything about it he just
has to he
he can rebutter but you know he can't
sue her can't you expel members of
congress
uh not for that nope but do you need a
reason
if they vote for well not not first not
for saying something on how on
the senate floor that's it they cannot
be expelled for that
they can be expelled for for collusion
or
or for conspiracy but you know just
questioning something
to bring out uh election uh
issues in a debate and a discussion
there in the clear it's all it's all uh
a left-wing talking point oh right on
tyler henderson says will you guys start
discussing cryptocurrency at any point
in time
we do periodically and let me just say
y'all y'all who sold
y'all are dumb because bitcoin dropped
pretty far went down to like 30
30 500 and i saw these people being like
there's a story coming out saying people
are going to lose everything
sell sell sell and i've been buying and
i'm like
don't that you'll make a huge mistake if
you do people who are buying at 30.
and so exactly so i sat back put my feet
up and watched it go right back up to
35.
imagine all those people who saw go to
30 panicked and sold and now it's back
with 35 you just lost your
you you want womp this is lydia's
favorite topic
he loves talking about cryptocurrencies
and bitcoin so if you have any related
information
definitely send it to uh at lydia but uh
thank you but yes
don't follow the market like a blind
sheep a lot of people buy at the top and
sell at the bottom that's not what
you're supposed to do
you just financial advice but again
don't don't play it like the average
yeah yeah i'll just tell you what i do
and again i can't give you financial
advice you got to take that on your own
i'll tell you what i do
i think it was dumb of people to sell i
when i buy i buy it and i hold
it's it's total hold on for dear life
because
66 percent of us dollars created in the
past what nine months
sixty-six percent in the money supply
well it's all wrinkled and gross because
they had to read they had to remake it
but it's an increased
money supply this has not happened
before
so who knows what's gonna happen and i
think bitcoin is
i i've said it before i think it'll be a
million dollars per coin at some point
in the near future
but that's not that's not that's not an
opinion i made up out of nowhere
that's when you listen to the experts
and the people who know what they're
talking about they tell you
based on the the technology and what it
is and what it does
and the fact that all of these massive
multinational billion dollar
corporations are buying in for whole
like
to hold assets told value it's just
there it's it's a good store of value
and it's gonna keep going up my friend
sean
uh actually was saying that he was gonna
hook me up with some advice about crypto
uh because
that's he's like i'm not doing politics
right now anymore i'm not doing
you know uh so he's he's all
he's all in on crypto right now uh and
he can afford it because he's
super rich but sean get you know
remember to get back to me because uh
i i wanna i wanna play this game when
bitcoin hit 20 bucks
everybody was like oh freaking out a lot
of people were buying and then it
dropped way down
and everyone's like oh it was a bubble
and it burst it was hype it was a trend
and then it jumps up again to a hundred
then it jumps again to a thousand i
remember when hit a thousand people were
like what and i was like wow
i was like how am i going to buy in now
at a thousand right geez because you can
buy fractions all the down to eight
that's just points
so every step of the way the trend has
been
entirely predictable what happens is the
people who mine the bitcoins who produce
them
this is my understanding i could be
wrong it's not a financial advice this
is just what i read and what i based my
opinions on
they they start producing bitcoin okay
so they get them through running the
software they're running the hardware to
generate it
then at some point something happens
politically or in the markets and people
rush and flock to
store their money out of fear this
causes a huge spike so we've recently
had like jp morgan and a bunch of other
banks saying bitcoin is going to be huge
we're buying in like crazy
once the pipe the price skyrockets the
people who mine the bitcoin go
now now's the time we sell to get
maximum value out of the out of the
effort we put into producing them
the mass sell-off drives the price way
down because
everybody's waiting to buy at lower
prices and then once that once the
miners clear their stock it starts going
back up because the demand is still
there
you're getting all this lydia yes
over here yeah anyway what's your
twitter account again no no
no bitcoin information
i'll learn about it and it's interesting
so do what you want to do
i'm not i don't you know look i listen i
just i see tweets from max kaiser and
i'm like i'm gonna buy bitcoin you know
what i mean
have fun staying poor that's the meme
we'll see we'll see maybe everyone
you can't win if you don't play that's
true well i don't think it's about
winning i think it's just
these are these are uncertain times in
my opinion not advice i'm just saying
for me
i was really worried when i saw them
mass printing this money biden saying
he's gonna do another big round of
stimulus
he's just basically devaluing the money
there's nothing being produced
i'm i shut up i want that free money
free money
shut up just stop don't break don't do
it like don't all right
student of history says ladies and
gentlemen in these trying times work on
yourselves
think of ways to improve your local
community organize the local level to
push peacefully
for change and find ways to separate
your community from the big
uh the big buoys be constructive please
good advice great advice vote
vote local look you can you can worry
about voting for
president every four years but but uh
really real real change happens on the
local level
with your city council with your uh your
assembly person
and your your state senator it's all
super important
every election is important don't don't
concentrate on just
once every four years and vote with your
dollar and also vote with your attention
but most importantly take
care of yourself so you could take care
of others that's another important
lesson i mean i guess
so i i can't read japanese but they say
i love you tim okay thank you very much
and then gina can you try i can't know
oh it's like a bunch of lies it's uh is
it kanji i think
i don't know uh geno fast says i love
you luke oh
i love you too thank you yes all right
let's see we got here
martin the panda says parlor data was
quote unquote hacked sort of
it was lazy coding on parlor's part but
all data available by the ips is being
scraped and archived including videos
images and posts
i believe that's true but that doesn't
mean anything it basically means someone
archived parlor and
okay thank you i guess there was this
big rumor going around that all of the
private information and ids was being
was hacked or whatever and
that was a few weeks ago but it was
same stupid lie and i saw everybody just
posting it because someone on reddit
made the claim and then someone screen
shot it posted on twitter
and i'm like did anybody google this
they didn't even bother googling and it
looked legit
you know like like it wasn't but it was
q q style
conspiracy like giving someone a vague
description
of jargon so it sounds legitimate like
the api access resource was exposed now
i'm not big on this stuff but what that
means
is the pseudo file that's used for the
import
allowed them to access your private
information they're like whoa
those are crazy words i've never heard
before it must be true
in related news twitter just announced
that they got rid of 70
000 users for sharing this is this is
what they're saying
cue associated content that's the word
that we're getting right now officially
uh i've lost half my followers
thank you that's crazy they were all
your followers just
it's just a way to purge the right once
again and the left keeps growing and
twitter is pushing this
and it is creating a mono culture and it
is getting
creepy well if you see on twitter you
see a lot of right-wing politicians
losing
a lot of followers but you see a lot of
democratic people gaining followers so i
even saw swalwell
tweet look how many great new followers
i have thank you again so much for
following me so that should tell you
what's happening well there's a
different there's
i think there's a difference between new
users
right these are these democrats who are
being followed they're
they're not from new users they're from
existing users
the the republicans who are leaving are
leaving yeah they're
they're canceling their their accounts
their their username so
there's you know there's a difference
it's not like it's balancing out for
for twitter definitely not twitter like
twitter is
probably in trouble a little bit how how
much trouble do you think that
twitter is in the long run i think
they're in serious trouble
yeah there was a comment i think made by
an investor's report that said
conservatives are fleeing they think
eventually political activists
might end up choosing twitter and stay
but uh twitter was dying before trump
they they they were it was it was
burning users they tried changing the
way they account metrics to sell better
like oh
we're gonna go through to monthly active
users instead of daily active users you
know why
how many people on on twitter are active
every single day
not that many right how many are active
in a month so you make what
i don't know exactly how the the metric
counting worked but the idea i i assume
or i i remember reading could be wrong
just preface that
was like if you tweet once in a month
you're considered a monthly active user
or something like that whereas when they
did daily active users
some people don't tweet the day you know
so they were like screwing with the
numbers trying to make it look like they
were growing but it was like you could
see the users were going down
and then trump came along and then
everybody in the world was like traps
tweeting
88 million followers it's just
now he's gone and i'm sure a lot of
people are just like what's the point of
being on twitter anymore
yeah that's actually a good point but
also for the left too
you know we were talking about like you
know brooklyn dad defiant
and and all these people it's like where
where you know trump they have a
notification when
when trump posts and they're like okay
what's the thing i'm gonna say right now
like what's my rebuttal some of them are
bots
people don't realize this some of whom
not not defiant brooklyn dad defiant
no i know i don't know no he's not
please don't tell me but some
some of them would just respond to trump
with some nonsense like
trump would tweet something where it's
like the radical left in this country is
trying to subvert the constitution we'll
never allow this this country will not
be socialist
and then you'd see a reply guy say
something like yeah coming from
from you it just shows how dumb you are
because they would have
automatic great job that were generic
but it worked and they would get
hundreds of thousands of followers and
then reply saying
make sure to buy my shirts and then they
would sell shirts where it's like trump
is so dumb
and it worked and they made a ton of
money you know what else works this was
a booming and i see this like once a
week now where somebody's like
i just quit amazon i quit my job because
my i have principals and i was making
220 000 a year
also i'm black follow me and it's like
they just made an account like a week
ago
and and then all these people retweet
them and they're like oh my god
this guy's a patriot you know it's like
yeah it's fake he's
some guy like you know from eastern
europe is
making a fake account daniel maxwell
says luke the only government that you
can trust is one that is afraid of its
own citizens
but only as long as that government is
afraid of its own citizens
poland is poland afraid of its citizens
uh well it depends there's a lot of
debates going on
uh specifically with the polish
government and some protests and
pushback against it
um i wouldn't say the government's
scared but i think the government
does realize that essentially the power
is with our consent
and once we understand that i think we
uh they lose a lot
a lot of leverage so um i think that's
why it's very important to let people
know that they have absolutely a lot of
power
and that they shouldn't be feeling
disenfranchised at all
smooth play johnny j says tim in your
opinion why does the career of
journalism attract more liberals than
conservatives
i love your show keep it the great work
good sir because news organizations are
based in cities that's it
that's the only reason so there are
conservatives
who work in media but if you live in a
city you're much more likely to be
left than if so the people who live near
these institutions
are more likely to go and apply and get
jobs and they're more likely to be rich
because news organizations don't pay
very well so there was this like
a big thing happened in new york where
people were kind of screaming about it
the only people who are getting jobs the
new york times are rich kids you know
why
because your parents pay your bills and
you work for nothing
you want to work at the new york times
okay start as an unpaid intern how is it
possible to be an unpaid intern in new
york city
it's too expensive but if your parents
pay your bills you can do it
so it's the rich kids it is rich it is
upper class
white progressives getting these jobs
they're coming from colleges where
they're learning about a bunch of stupid
things and then that becomes the
narratives at these institutions
even surprisingly a lot of people at fox
news
oh yeah look i i've worked in newsrooms
where you know
like all the all the people covering
finance
they're they're right-leaning for the
most part
uh but every just about everybody else
other than
you know uh depending where you are like
your editorial board
is either like all the way to the right
or all the way to the left
uh but for the most part i'd say most
journalists
are are definitely left-wing
left-leaning
well it's because they're in cities yeah
it's true gareth green says i
fundamentally disagree with your
collectivist philosophy of the commons
i don't believe that anyone has the
right to use anything they don't own
but that doesn't mean i can't
acknowledge and denounce the suppression
of dissent by social media
i don't know i think uh i i don't
believe we could function i've argued
with so many and caps and libertarians
about
the ownership of common resources and
the argument always comes down to like
something simple like
upstream water use and downstream water
use and water rights and things like
this
and we have we have to have some kind of
uh agreement
because you if like i've been told
someone could just own
a portion of the river and do whatever
they want and i'm like yeah well the
people downstream are going to get angry
when you take a dump in it and they're
going to come up with pitchforks
they're like but it's my you know okay
look there's a lot of arguments we can
have
i think there are common things we have
to agree on otherwise
i'll just buy the river because i have
the power to do so you know what i mean
i don't think you're an ad cap or
anything andrew you're looking at me
like no no i'm just listening
yeah so are you from the concept of the
commons
no like uh the town center like i'm
learning right now so
uh it's it's the shared resources of a
local community
you know so you build a bunch of houses
there's an area that no one you know
owns like it's a road or something it's
commonly used
one day someone comes and destroys it
while we take issue with that
so the way i describe twitter and
facebook is that it's become the
political space for it's the commons
meaning it's the area where we all
gather to communicate and share ideas
and what's happened now is where we used
to go to churches
and we used to go to town halls we now
go on social media
and it's basically akin to someone
setting up giant walls around
town hall saying you can come in to have
a political discussion on the issues
if you agree with our opinions so it's
like well if i want to come and have a
political debate to change the rules and
the laws here and you're not letting me
in because you don't like my opinions
then how can i participate anymore you
can't and then you get crushed out so
i'm not a fan of monopolizing power for
in any capacity be it left be it free
market
maybe at oligarchs be it government
let's read some more
let's see we got here we'll try and jump
down and grab some uh poofy says
redeem these nuts
hi poofy for that very astute
observation yes
my operative uh i don't walk runs
poofy definitely helps me out with
scripts uh and and insight and actually
i was
talking about the electoral college the
electoral college the other day
and uh like i was on the phone with her
on discord and just like yelling at her
i'm like you don't
understand i don't understand like it's
the state's rights
she's like but like you know she she
agrees but you know
uh we had it we had a little
conversation i love you poofy you're
awesome
bucky wilson could you guys plus gal
recommend any resources to teach a
beginner
start a business podcast stream 36 year
old laid off second wave
co 19 tired of working for people um
the motley fool well i'll tell you i
think too many people
think i don't i don't know everybody's
trying to podcast right now podcast
equipment got sold out the prices like
elgato stream decks are through the room
oh my gosh
to the roof and it was because it's
something you can do when you're locked
in your house podcast
but i also think too many people look to
popular mediums and assume
it's something they should do or that
you know listen
just because you're seeing something
doesn't mean you'd be doing something
you know what i mean like yeah
i know a lot of people who want to be
actors just because movies and shows are
so prominent and i'm like do you like
acting
no but it's a good way to make money i'm
like there's a lot of ways you sell
t-shirts to make money you know what i
mean
so uh for those if you really do want a
podcast i would say
um you need a good capture card the
elgato uh
was it 4k capture usb stick is pretty
good i use those when i travel but we
have actual
you know pci cards that go in the
machine blackmagic has capture cards
a good camera is going to be crazy
there's some good sonys that are super
cheap little handheld cams and you can
do a micro hdmi to hdmi
and get a good microphone this is the
sm7b
and it is just because everyone uses it
everyone uses it and i'm sure they're
about our microphones
but i like them there's usb microphones
you can
not a fan but you don't need the best
kind of equipment starting off
no especially if you're starting off
just try to focus
on things that someone else is not doing
a lot of people try to be someone that
they're not
and i think that's when they get caught
up a great book i would recommend
rich dad poor dad i would definitely
recommend that and and look for
problems in our society and try to fix
them and those
will lead to perfect opportunities for
you to be an entrepreneur
because there's a lot of problems right
now there's very little people trying to
solve them
you know what i you know how i got
started i had a gopro 4 and now just put
it on top of the monitor and press
record
that's it well it sounded awful it
looked weird
and whatever man i still use a webcam
like
and it's okay and it and it's fine and
the quality is there
uh but but it really does matter about
you
as an individual being unique and
accepting your uniqueness and doing
something that someone else is not doing
that's the key
that's the recipe uh in my opinion
towards success yeah i
i agree that you don't need i mean look
at shoe on head
i mean how long did she have that potato
cam like for
a long long still does what do you mean
oh i thought she upgraded did she
yeah she upgraded it yeah but uh but but
it
no it wasn't i mean she would say it was
you know it was and it had like you know
it was like 54 frames per second
you know uh not not great equipment but
it's all about it's it's all about the
content
right right and not you know i
i think talk about what you're
passionate about you know
but this is not for everybody look
you've seen me on tonight i'm not
no i can't do this
but it's this it is not it is not for
everybody it is not easy
but you don't know unless you try you
know i mean i had
for a very very long time for about a
year and a half i had about
less than 600 subscribers but i wanted
to do it
i was it was just me being creative i
never thought that i would be at
now 420 000 subscribers is crazy
right it's great 420 man you know but i
honestly i
i just wanted to do because i wanted to
do it if you if you do do it
do not think you know dude it's not a
guarantee that
you're going to blow up because there's
a lot of people to do it
so you know do it do it because you want
to do it do it don't do it
because you think that it's going to be
like a get rich thing you're going to be
like the next
uh sour patch lids
all right grant shearer says tim the
bible says certain things will happen to
jewish and christian nations that turn
away from god
ever since god started being removed
from society those things have been
happening
google consequences of nations who turn
away from god
okay i guess i don't know um
i've been here i've been hearing this
more and more that people are claiming
revelations is starting to happen
but i wonder if it has more to do with
political turmoil giving people anxiety
so they're looking for the signs i mean
they said back in the 80s
that you know it was going to be the end
of the world you know like
pat robertson you know saying like the
the
news it's always you know the the
rapture is gonna happen
you know i've been hearing that for a
while yeah i remember
i remember my mom going oh i can't
believe that we're in this time and it's
not fair
and you know thinking that the rapture
was gonna happen i was just like
uh okay you know just because the man on
tv said it doesn't mean it's gonna
happen but you know
uh she also thought there was gonna be
like you know nuclear war too but that's
that's another thing
we were close vixen valentine says i
love the addition of luke to the show
has a different viewpoint and very
respectable knowledgeable man and he's
gorgeous
i hope he stays on side note did luke
name his dog yet
ah you killed it for me because i was
actually no super chat
because i was gonna sag into that later
when i when i talked about my instagram
and i was going to be like look at the
look at luke's dog we already doesn't
have a name
the largest super chat names the dog and
people something like 20 bucks and stuff
and uh we named it grogu
[Laughter]
um well we're debating between atlas
pooper
freedom there's all their names sage
is one of them luke jr she's a she's a
really good dog no we named her fumble
bump
bubble bum it's perfect for an
apocalypse dog or a prepper dog
so so the other day luke was trying to
coax fumble bump to him with treats
and i grabbed this bag of swedish candy
which the dog was not going to eat and i
kept jiggling it
and she was looking back and forth and i
was yelling fumble bump and he was
yelling freedom
she chose fumble bombs wow snap she
picked well because you had the snacks
he had snacks too oh he had real hit
real dog treats
i had this like swedish candy the dog
wasn't allowed to eat he had
well if you guys want to see the dog go
to my instagram
at don't walk run productions all one
word don't walk around productions
i still need i still need to get 10 000
subscribers okay so i can do polls and
stuff
but uh but the the dog is is is very
cute and
uh it was it was i'm two days no i'm so
blessed
at all she already knows how to sit how
to lay down
german shepherds are smart by design
like that's all underneath
it's like ten weeks now so i'm pretty
impressed all right jm says is there
much difference between fringe trump
supporters who
thought trump was sending them secret
messages to cease congress
and the left to accuse trump of dog
whistling them to attack congress
no the only difference is whether they
like trump or don't yeah
oh man the livestream where they're like
trump's going to be happy with us
oh yes they're both mentally ill that's
that's the problem dude the thing is
though
guess which one gets banned the right
not the left of course
so these these conspiracy leftists who
for years i'm not gonna name some of
these people but some of these people
have
hundreds of thousands of followers
they're verified and they say the
stupidest and craziest things like
steve bannon is facing the death penalty
for treason then lynnwood says mike
pence is facing the death melee for
treason
it's all nuts it's really crazy
i mean i'll tell you man the level of
unhinged psychosis that i've seen on
social media these past months
have made me have some deep
philosophical conversations about the
right to acts on a platform
and whether or not we should just ban
them all outright i'm like here's the
compromise
just bend it for everybody no one's
allowed to use social media just go back
to the days of radio
or the record player like joe biden i
mean if we're going to ban politicians
let's ban all of the politicians from
using the platform
if we're going to expel republicans
let's compromise expel all of them
yes and the democrats all of them make
paul you know start over yeah it's it i
was watching
uh i was watching some i think i was
watching fox and they were saying
well how's the president gonna
communicate to people if he's not on
twitter like
he has a press office like it's not that
hard
you know like he still has a
communications director well the
senate the media decides to cover him
because they were already
trusting him and cutting him off but of
course they're going to cover him now
because
you know they need to maybe they need to
say every
joseph moore says tim how can people
remain peaceful and say what happened in
dc was wrong while also in the same
stroke
just say if things remain uh to course
big tech will soon control all ways of
life
i don't think remaining passive will
change where we are heading from
fury quote ideals are peaceful history
is violent history is violent
but we're in a different technological
age and i think that's the issue
so i i was saying this earlier on my
show over the weekend
i did less segments partly because
everybody needs to chill and i was like
you know what man
it's like people were screaming at the
top of their lungs on twitter that's
what i saw i turned on twitter and it
was like
that episode of rick and morty where the
sun comes up and screaming the whole
time
yeah that's what happens when you open
the twitter app it's like
i'm just scrolling it's all i see and i
was like i'm just going to do it like i
woke up in the morning
and there were some things i felt like
talking about so i did segments i said
i'm not going to read anymore
and we went to the woods you know we
threw rocks
and skipped stones broke the ice there
was no broke some ice yeah there was no
internet
at all and uh we made a fire and we just
kind of chilled in the middle of nowhere
and i was like people need to relax man
you need to chill so i think you know
mike cernovich said it get offline
you know go to your loved ones and just
drop this kind of like
we need to chill pull back and just calm
down the dog was running around there
was no service
and i have to remind people uh you got
to work on your mental health when
you're on social media you're on a
device that literally
rots your brain and destroys your mental
health there's many studies showing this
uh look into taking a day off maybe i
mean i i started taking some days off
because uh
you need to you need to decompress you
need to get away from it all and i was
very happy to have that nice nature day
took a took the total day off
um and also most importantly meditate
nap or whatever if ashwagandha is your
thing do your
do something that's good for you at
least once a week because
uh right now we need it more than ever
well i think one one way to approach
things like twitter is it's not real
life
at all just uh you know i i get very
argumentative
on twitter because it's fun for me
because i'm not taking it seriously
i'm i'm definitely i like calling people
out i'm right all the time
but uh but i i mean it's that's fun for
me
i think like parlor parlor's fine but
it's an echo chamber
and that's what twitter's turning into
it's going to be an echo chamber with
all these conservatives to fight with
without trump um you're out of a job and
you know brooklyn dad defiant you know
sorry next next super chat please thank
you you're good we're a little
distracted we're looking something up
yeah somebody somebody mentioned that
all of gab's tweets are now gone
what what oh tweets on twitter right on
twitter
oh accounts there the tweets are gone
which is weird weird
let's see destroying evidence right
kledgy says ben shapiro is a rad dude
yes he is j maxx's love him or hate him
ben shapiro is one of the few pundits
that constantly encourages his audience
to watch listen
to his opposition and tells his
listeners to come to their own
conclusions
that is the absolute right thing to do
that's cool and so i try to make sure
i do the same like if you're only
watching me you're that you're in bad
shape you know you got to watch
everybody
i try my best but you don't end up
happening is i get
like i'm not going to name the
personality i was like go check out this
guy's video he did a video very similar
to mine but
he's on the other side of the you know
other opposite perspective
and then i got a bunch of comments from
people being like i watched what he was
saying and it was all wrong and poorly
fact checked and i'm like
probably why i disagree with him you
know what i mean so that's why i
encourage you to go find out i'm just
making this stuff
up but i get things wrong a lot it's so
weird
that i'll be like here's what i think
might happen and then i'm wrong and then
like these leftists are like
tim was wrong and i was like yeah i
don't think i'm like the smartest guy in
the world like
do you think i think i am like i always
call myself a dude of complains on the
internet it was an opinion
you know you're not you're not saying
well this is definitely absolutely gonna
happen
but uh my favorite is when i was like if
trump appoints tulsi gabbard as
uh uh security advisor it could happen
andrew yang as economic advisor and then
decriminalizes pot
49 state landslide and then they cut
that first part out and then use the
last part and it's like
dude i'm talking about hypotheticals
pertaining to riots and what might
contribute to like
a hypothetical historical moment you
know what i mean well
just just to jump on uh to add
to tim's uh commentary here definitely
look like read everything be like sarah
palin
read everything right uh i like one
video that i did i i i needed like a
breakdown
of what was in bernie's medicare for all
plan
and the best analysis was on vox
and i used it as a source on my you know
i said
vox.com did an analysis and i got so
much pushback in the comments where
they're like
why are you using vox i'm like because
it was a good analysis
like you know they don't they don't not
everything is bad that they
i i love using left wing sources when
they're calling out the left
because that creates it's kind of like a
dude if vox is calling them out yeah
come on we're not making this up
right right exactly and and that's why i
don't i generally
you know when i am doing sources when i
am like trying to prove a point
i will use the washington post as much
as possible or the new york times or vox
or
um you know salon or slate or whatever
because it just it shows that i wasn't
like well he's just getting all of his
sources from fox you know it's like
that's that's not true
all right let's see black czar says
progressives stating that they believe
free speech is a human right while
advocating for the removal of descending
voices is not
a contradiction no as they do not
perceive such people as human
only humans have human rights i guess
it's an argument
because there is a big dehumanization
agenda trying to make your political
opponents look as
ugly and as deceitful and as nasty as
possible yeah
it no it's you're you're right you're
right i mean we
that's you're right you're just that's
it no there's a revolt they're demanding
to know what happened to ian
yeah um
ian was kind of off his game tonight
yeah honestly feeling sick
yeah i don't know i walked off the show
before when i had a big migraine
yeah it happened he got he got a new
gorilla
you know and so maybe too much gorilla
energy kind of overwhelming
it overwhelms me yeah yeah because now
he had the glowing gorilla and now the
other it's a lot of
gorilla rage they're both they're both
yelling and doing kind of the same thing
you know i get it clayton says tell luke
i joined cmu
i want to start having an impact not
enough people get real news thanks to
all you're greatly appreciated
especially sour patch lids oh thanks
nice cmu is
change media university it's an online
program that i have that teaches people
the steps of how to be
an independent journalist very cool it's
on we are change.org and then we have a
cmu section that you guys could check
out
sweet know that let's see eric miller
says i disagree with luke
there was there's theirs was many
cultures because we had the internet
and don't have the attention span to
hold on to a culture for a decade
it could be true i think i think you i
think you bring up a valid point and uh
i will social media is awful yeah yeah
i think yeah so what we what we're
seeing is there was there was a dominant
culture
more so in each decade and now we have
fractured cultures because of the
internet
and so these cultures are fighting each
other the culture war
they don't agree with everything people
don't agree with each other
but there's no innovation that's the
thing in my opinion
there's a lot of recycling yeah all
right let's see i looked up gab i can
see their tweets
oh yeah i can see them all of them what
do you mean i can see them
fake news on my phone really yeah
sure can yep when i go on twitter and
pull up get on gab there's three
interesting well there's three tweets
there are at least three
there's at least one you're seeing more
than three on the phone i thought i was
seeing like
15. it could be that you have uh so the
twitter app store it's like
cash or something yeah maybe so
interesting yeah
scott brumley says i cancelled my
audible amazon account but left product
book reviews posting
what i would have posted on parlor if i
could everyone should do this sort of
thing that's actually
really funny leave reviews of your
parlor comments
way to go good job wow that's smart
you could use the comment section of a
product as a
feed to communicate that's crazy but
they could
eventually they would catch on and ban
your ip probably and then you just ch
you just change it and it's like you
could you could say like
you know follow me on uh you know the
harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
reviews
yeah and then you're just posting what
you think and it'd be great
yeah arguing with people and has nothing
to do with the book but it's a platform
by which you can post things you know
uh luke what what uh what
famous literature should we follow you
at on
definitely and then when they censor the
comments on 1984 would be glorious oh
snap
so we've been having some issues with
the website
because we just we just put it up so
timcast.com we just launched someone
saying
it was working just a few moments ago
just a few moments ago yeah okay yeah
what's up yep
so uh cool cool cool yeah you couldn't
go i reloaded it you could go to gab we
got to increase our
capacity you could go to gab on twitter
but you could also
go uh on youtube and look at my website
my
channel instagram don't walk around
productions thank you excellent yeah
very smooth i like that
or my instagram don't walk around
productions all one word
gab let's see i'm not getting any money
from gab more super chats a couple more
technically
america aegis says tim what has stopped
me from going out and doing anything is
financial responsibility to my family
i'm figuring out a way to fix that to
protect my family i'm here for america
yeah i think the best thing people need
to do is uh
get off social media and build local
community culture
uh little league games skate park i went
to skatepark the other day and it was
like desolate
and it's kind of crazy you know and i
and a lot of people have been saying oh
but you know skateboarding's on the way
i'm like it's actually not the olympics
are getting skateboarding this time
around
it's a huge deal there's a lot of money
being dumped into this so where are the
events where people go to the parks
whether you're barbecuing and having a
beer if you can i don't know if you can
actually do that at the park
or you're you know your kids are
skateboarding and there's like an event
going on
we need more local events i guess covid
has stopped that
and it's forcing everybody onto the
internet where they're screaming
just turn opening up twitter well when i
say well when i say the twitter isn't
real life
um i've done man on the street
interviews where i've said you know we
just had an election
did you vote yeah who's your who's your
state senator
oh schumer uh no that's your that's your
u.s senator who's your state senator
and so many people don't know because a
lot of people are
like you look at twitter and you think
the world is nuts about politics
it is not uh normal everyday people
care about like little league games and
you know they're
maybe like a local a local issue or
something but they're
not super political like just watching a
local news channel and it was just like
police officers pulled over a man
on 7th and main yesterday who was
driving without a taillight and it's
like i'm like wow
the news they care about these small
towns oh yeah well even
i mean local news in general is pretty
you know uh
when you talk about how journalism is
you know
dying not for these local stations no no
no local stations local stations yeah
they're on fire
it's just because everyone's going
national
all people follow on social media's
national news donald trump
but because of this we're not learning
about the things that are really
affecting oh yeah where we live that's
that's that's really bad so
this is what you do to save you want to
save this country
have local events to whatever degree you
can with the coveted lockdowns
uh encourage people to meet talk to your
neighbors
just that kind of community gathering
man it used to be at churches
we're not a particularly religious
country anymore i mean we are still
overwhelmingly christian but a lot of
people aren't really
practicing as heavily and so the
get-togethers don't happen
we need that you gotta you like the
neighbors gotta come together and have
like a barbecue or something or yeah
you know whenever yeah exactly when you
come with it there's been also a
cultural
attempt to fracture the family and we're
at a point where family members are
snitching on other family members that
were in washington dc to the fbi
and the mainstream media is glorifying
that and promoting that right now
which just shows you the kind of in my
opinion the larger narrative and agenda
that's being being
pushed by hollywood and all these other
very powerful institutions saying stay
away from your family family bad
and supporting this kind of individual
lifestyle that is
uh very uh just gluttonous
and uh decrepit in my opinion creepy
stuff yeah
eric no no yes noise says why didn't i
get a notification that you were live
i had to come check your youtube channel
yes but we're we're live monday through
friday at 8pm so you know you can always
just come to watch the show if you want
to watch a show and that's
that's the thing you the biggest driver
of views on youtube is recommendations
and natural pull is when people
that's what the phrase for when someone
says i choose to turn this show on
for tucker carlson he gets views not
because it's being recommended but
because people every day say i want to
watch him
that is way more powerful than my views
on youtube so i can sit here and be like
oh i get millions of views per day on my
show on youtube yeah but youtube's
pushing it
tucker gets people to come to his show
so that's way bigger
so if you like the show just gotta show
up and uh also
we're gonna have a bunch of exclusive
content and exclusive live streams
on timcast.com it's gonna have a
membership section
and then we're we're gonna be building a
lot of new stuff something really cool
but we've got this new
area set up this new venue we're gonna
have like a live stage and music it's
gonna be fun
streamed members only and we're gonna
invite people
out here you'll get to come to the
studio if you're a member when we put up
the tickets and
we sent out the email but they're very
limited so i imagine we're gonna have a
ridiculous amount of members and like 20
available tickets so
become a member timcast.com same thing
with saturday night live though
you know you can wait in a standby line
and never ever
see the inside of uh 6a so yeah you know
it happens but
you know it it just sounds really fun it
sounds really cool i
i'm got this little stage set up and
it's still a little bit cold so i don't
know if we're going to we want to set
everything up just yet
but we're going to have we have an area
for stand up sit down interviews and for
music this little stage we built
and it's like skateboarding and you know
we're going to have comedians and music
and start getting that stuff set up too
because we a lot of the guests we have
are musicians or comedians
or even political commentary so there
can be a sort of stand-up political
discussion not necessarily comedy but i
think you would be really great at like
doing a live version of one of your
videos andrew
where you like have like a screen and
you break things down yeah maybe
yeah it would be great and then people
would come hang out have a beer it
wouldn't be like a regular venue it'd be
like people standing around
having like burgers and sipping a beer
but we'd stream it live
and that's it you hear that i'm being
invited so i'm holding that to you
yeah it'll be great too and like i'm
sure we'll have jack murphy around all
the time
jack's awesome people love jack so yeah
so that's what we're getting ready for
and uh it's funny though the left is
like really critical of us having guests
here but it's all within the coveted
guidelines and like
like it's not it's like one guest at a
time yeah we've got hand sanitizer and
we clean things it's like
i don't know what do you think is going
on it's like one person
okay
[Laughter]
sorry i don't know you don't want to
smell that microphone that's all i'm
saying
uh we have this is the alex jones
microphone
but we have the covers for for people
and everything like that um
i don't know the thing is going on we're
not in the uk where it's like you can't
leave your house you know what i mean
yeah i don't know whatever but it's
going to be fun and i think the limit
right now is 50 people
and we're probably gonna have 20 which
is totally normal and like
allowed no super spreader events here
and what would take it seriously you
know
i'm not good all right that's a good one
but i'm not going to read it david uh uh
eliason says i am a gorilla
and i'm not going to read the rest of
that
says sorry tim on the 20 max show if
they are fan funded for those who can't
afford to go 20 lucky fans could go
on all expenses paid fan experience and
a vlog
of the whole experience would be amazing
thanks for all the spice
yeah maybe we could actually do
something like that where uh we could
have
like a lottery winner i i just i just
it's like i just hate lotteries
it's like you sign up and you're
crossing your fingers hoping that you
get to come and there's like 10 000
people and then when you don't win you
get salty
yeah yeah yeah it's a bummer but i guess
how salty would it be if like you're
sitting there checking your email and
the email comes in and you click it and
your phone's like error loading
because the site's overloaded and just
like with the ps5 it's also going to be
annoying
i know is anybody gonna i thought it was
like look i'm enough of an influencer
that i get to see a ben shapiro movie
early but
but uh congratulations you know but and
and thank you daily wire that's nice of
you to think of me but
and you got your money's worth because i
talked about it on
on the top uh the top
podcast what would you call this well
livestream podcast the pot
the top thing on youtube it's a thing
yeah yeah the top thing
you know you know the thing i do know
people are saying that when they try to
log into the website it's giving them an
error well we will get
we'll take care of that immediately
amazon just went up
just went up so we've got to upgrade our
hosting and
it's it's going to happen you know the
secret to starting a business is always
just start it
and then you've got to iterate and fix
as you build you know you start getting
through the bugs and stuff like that
so when we had it when it went live
everything's working just fine for us
and i'm like okay we're good to go and
we're probably going to get inundated
with so many people it's going to cause
errors and crashes
and we'll get it sorted growing pains
it's it's day one of the site being up
you're not the lotus eaters oh yeah
cause there's
it's like eight months before uh carl
carl's website's amazing no yeah well
what happened was they
uh from what i understand they hired
somebody uh
they went live it kind of uh you know
hit the bed
and they basically had to bring in like
people who actually knew what they were
doing
yeah so this is carl benjamin's podcast
sargon of cod right aka sargon his great
website yes
the lotus eaters podcast i saw his
website and i was like man this is
really good
it's like i'm jealous yeah and and a
website like that and they have probably
like the second best
live stream slash podcast thing on here
on youtube it's doing really well yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it's nowhere near as good as we are no
no we're tooting our own horn guys but
carl's awesome carl you rock and uh he's
had
his his show's been skyrocketing yeah
like in the in the rankings way to go
sargon yeah cool
cool show for sure and it's it's like
it's more british centric i guess
right they cover a lot they cover a lot
of stuff they cover a lot of american
politics
for sure oh yeah yeah carl always has
yeah oh yeah but like they
like today they covered uh the pelosi
coo
oh wow and uh yeah they they covered
they cover a lot of american politics
but but they're not stupid about it they
know they know what they're talking
about all right all right we'll do one
more super chat the most important super
chat nicholas keller says tim get those
nerds to work we need your site up
now come on man i think i think we're on
it i think i think we are on it
and uh that's what it's it's
maybe we need to seriously upgrade
everything uh just because i didn't know
how many people were gonna you know come
in and try and sign up immediately
but it's probably more than we expected
you're a popular person
oh i'm so famous aren't i you're an
influencer yeah i'm an influencer with
so many oh
you know what man it was so much easier
when i had a lot less followers and i'm
so humble no no but let's be real let's
be real
i remember when i had like 120 000
subscribers on youtube and i was living
comfortably
and i wasn't getting the flack and
wasn't getting the smears and the
attacks and the conspiracy theories and
the threats
and i'm like man you know mo money mo
problems
that song was right but uh you know it
comes in the territory so you can some
people can hang with it some people
can't
a lot of these journalists lose their
minds because they get harassing emails
and i'm just like i just ignore it i
just like filter words like if you email
me with certain words just go to the
garbage pile yeah it's not real
i mean you know if it's if it's a
credible threat you know
send it to the authorities there's one
thing going on right now that twitter
won't remove
and it's you know freaking out my family
yep and twitter's like well we looked at
it and we're not sure yet we'll get back
to you and i'm like
well you know thanks twitter i'd like to
call on amazon to suspend twitter
because they're refusing to moderate
this activity anyway if you haven't
already smash
that like button uh subscribe hit the
notification bell
and i'm not entirely sure what's going
on the site because you know it's
probably being slammed by everybody
trying to sign up but
you can go to timcast.com if not now
maybe later
sign up to become a member we're going
to have exclusive content
we're going to have exclusive live
streams some of it's going to be silly
we're going to vlog
the vlog will be coming soon once we get
to that point
covid really jammed everything up to be
completely honest
made it really hard to expand put
pressure on on subverse aka scanner
and so we're getting things in order but
we'll see how it goes with biden coming
in
if we're going to do more lockdown or
less that's you know been a big
challenge but uh anyway
go to timcast.com become a member sign
up if you are
already someone who is giving on paypal
you just need to request a new password
and you should already be a member and
so this is kind of a we think it creates
a benefit for everybody who signed up
early because you might get essentially
some kind of discount i'm not entirely
sure how it might work
but if you're already donating to the
old timecast.com donate then you're
already in the system
and uh if it's not working now just
check back later but also follow me
on twitter instagram and uh i normally
would say parliament
twitter instagram and mindsminds.com
tim cast where i do put up all my videos
and uh
for as long as any of this lasts i
appreciate it but you can check out my
other youtube channels
youtube.comtymcastyoutube.comcastnews
and uh we do the show monday through
friday live at 8pm
leave us a comment leave us a good
review andrew you're a you're a now
frequent guest but you have your own
youtube channel i do
uh it is don't walk around productions
you can just type in
don't walk run aoc no i'm just kidding
uh don't walk run
in the search bar and my channel will
come up uh you can follow me
on twitter at don't walk run all one
word and
if you want to see luke's dog again and
please follow me
please follow me on instagram at don't
walk run productions
i am not posting like every single day
i'm not annoying i swear but please
you know just uh follow me there
subscribe to my youtube because i'm
really
i don't post all the time there either
just like once a week
once a week i might allow you to exploit
the dog
later on today but also don't forget to
follow ian at
ian crossland he uh left but on all
platforms
that's correct and uh should i
luke who are you who the heck my youtube
channel is we are change but i would
become invincible
if you guys would just sign up to my
email list which you could very easily
do
on we are change.org in the right hand
top
corner that's it's a way for me to
actually have a list that can't be taken
away from me
and i think that's really important if
you want the t-shirt that i'm wearing
that says if you trust
government you don't know history you
could get it on we are change dot org
forward slash shirts and one last thing
uh today is actually the eight year
anniversary of the death of
aaron schwartz if you don't know who he
is look him up he's a very
important uh internet pioneer freedom
fighter
and he should be remembered through
everything
his life and his activism was incredible
and deserves a shout out
at least right on don't forget to follow
at sourpatch live yes i'm here in the
corner
worth the follow that's what andrew says
he keeps getting coins
absolutely worth the following yes tell
me all about bitcoin
learn i think the reason i don't like
listening to it is because i don't
understand it
so if you have someone who can explain
it really well for sure
we're all afraid of things that we don't
understand exactly so that's my issue
being scared is fun right imagine that
you said a rollercoaster they just
shouted words at you
that's what they do on twitter thanks
for hanging out everybody
we will return tim cast irl will return
for a sequel tomorrow at 8pm
live uh so thanks for hanging out we'll
see you all then bye-bye
you